Good morning, Sean. Good morning, Jason Beatman. Now, are you aware not only if we made a cast change here, we've gotten rid of the Will Arnett, it's just you and me and now, but we're also on a cooking show now. That is correct. Six-can chili.
早上好，肖恩。早上好，杰森·贝特曼。现在，你知道吗，我们不仅换了演员阵容，把威尔·阿奈特换掉了，现在只有你和我，而且我们现在还在一个烹饪节目里。没错。六罐辣椒。
Yep, that's what we're doing. What are we doing with the six cans of chili? Well, we're gonna do all the meat and all the veggies you can handle. Okay. We're gonna triple the tomato sauce and we're going to put in four kinds of garlic. Did you know there's four different kinds of garlic? No, what are they? Can you name them quickly?
对，这就是我们要做的。我们打算用这六罐辣椒做什么？我们要把你能吃下的所有肉和蔬菜都放进去。好的。我们要把番茄酱加到三倍，还要放四种大蒜。你知道大蒜有四种不同的品种吗？不知道，是什么？你能快点说出来吗？
Garlic, garlic or garlic ear and garlicness. It's gonna have a big fan of garlicness. Yeah, it's gonna have quite a kick to it. And you're gonna be, well, you're gonna be busy in the, in the restroom for a while with this, but boy, it's a great weight loss tool. And welcome to Six Can Chely with Sean and Jason. So Sean was just saying how he's he's a little groggy this morning because he's still wearing his Oscar hair from last night from his play
大蒜、大蒜或是大蒜耳和大蒜性。它会有一大群大蒜性的粉丝。对，它会有相当大的后劲。而且你呢，好吧，你会在洗手间里待上一阵子，不过天哪，这是个很棒的减肥方法。欢迎收看肖恩和杰森的《六罐辣椒》。肖恩刚才说他今天早上有点头脑不清，因为他昨天刚演完话剧，
So he's he did not shower after a sweaty theater performance just Well because I'm so fucking tired and I'm so hungry because I don't eat before the show So I had a massive bowl of spaghetti and ice cream and I think that's why I didn't sleep and I'm exhausted today They did a Raiders of the Lost Dark marathon. Was it last night or the Sunday? Last night, and because they were the AV guy who was here all day too, and I was here early, and then I'd get up for that, and I had the show of who cares?
还戴着奥斯卡颁奖典礼上的发型。所以他演完一场汗流浃背的话剧后根本没洗澡——好吧，因为我太他妈累了，又太饿了，演出前我什么都没吃。所以我吃了一大碗意大利面和冰淇淋，我想这就是我昨晚没睡好、今天筋疲力尽的原因。他们搞了个《夺宝奇兵》马拉松。是昨晚还是周日？昨晚，因为音响师一整天都在这儿，我来得很早，然后我得起那么早，而且我有演出，谁在乎呢？
Anyway, who cares? Did you ask your AV guy to join you in Scotty for the marathon? Yeah. Yeah. Don't laugh like that's not something you would do. Now, now let me ask you about the Raider's marathon. And my first question is why? Because the new one's coming out.
总之，谁在乎呢？你有没有叫你的音响师跟斯科蒂一起去看马拉松？有。别笑得好像这不是你会做的事一样。现在，现在让我问你关于《夺宝奇兵》马拉松的事。我的第一个问题是：为什么？因为新电影要上映了。
Sure, you got to get ready, Will. Oh, so you got to get teed up. Yeah, yeah. I'm so excited. You got to have everything fresh so you can tap your neighbor in the theater next to you and go, do you remember in part three where they kind of laid some breadcrumbs for this moment?
当然，你得做好准备，威尔。哦，所以你得热身。对，对。我太兴奋了。你得把所有剧情都温习一遍，这样你在影院里就能拍拍身旁邻居的肩膀说：“你还记得第三部分里，他们为这一刻埋下的伏笔吗？”
Yeah, man. I'm such a grouch. I'm such a grouch about this shit. I just realized that I'm like, just don't say anything. Are you going to go see the new Indiana Jones, right, Willie? You have to. I mean, yeah, I mean, it's the little boy and you dead. Yeah.
没错，兄弟。我真是个怪胎。我对这破事真是个怪胎。我刚刚意识到，就像是，什么也别说。你打算去看新上映的印第安纳·琼斯对吧，威尔？你必须去。我是说，对，当年的小男孩死……
When did you kill the little boy? Our guest is laughing. Listen, our guest is laughing. Here it is. So the guest is getting, the guest is getting fucking impatient. So here we're going to go, you don don't wanna piss this guy off, okay? Because today we have our first world famous DJ on the show. What?
你什么时候把那个小男孩给写死了？我们的嘉宾在笑。听着，我们的嘉宾在笑。就是这样。所以嘉宾开始，嘉宾开始他妈的不耐烦了。所以接下来我们要说，你可不想惹毛这家伙，好吧？因为今天我们的节目迎来了第一位世界著名的DJ。什么？
Okay. This music master is at the top of his game. Spinning and scratching for the fabulous and the famous. He's gonna tell us about his passion for music. His land speed record of 180 miles per hour and eventually will. Are you serious? We're having a DJ? Yeah, that's great. Nice, Will. He is undefeated, he has an undefeated record
好吧，这位音乐大师正处于他的巅峰状态。为名流巨星们打碟和搓盘。他要跟我们聊聊他对音乐的热情。他创下了每小时180英里的陆地速度纪录，而且最后——你是认真的吗？我们请来了一位DJ？对，这太棒了。干得好，威尔。他保持着不败纪录，他有着不败的纪录
in kickboxing. And is recent moment. This is a big and special thing. Yeah, this is like he always twits his earned. Recent momentum has been found in a new passion for acting. And this momentum has come in the form of multiple nominations and wins for BAFTA's Emmy's Saga and Golden Globe Awards, as well as box office earnings for his films reaching well over $9 billion.
并且在kickboxing中。最近的势头。这是一件大事，非常特别。对，这就像他总是炫耀自己的。最近的势头体现在他对表演的新热情上。这种势头表现为多次获得英国电影学院奖、艾美奖、美国演员工会奖和金球奖的提名及奖项，他参影的电影票房收入更是远超90亿美元。
So he's got some nice speed going here with his new passion. He's got a lot of stuff. He's also one of Time Magazine's 100 Most Influential People in the World. And most importantly was recently named People's Sexiest Man Alive. All of this and one man and he's here to tell us how he does it. Please welcome DJ Big AJ Big Dress, AKA Idris Elba. No way. No way. Woo. Oh, see. I was like, wait, what? Another classic Bateman intro.
所以他的新爱好让他发展得顺风顺水。他有很多成就。他还是《时代》周刊“全球最具影响力的100人”之一。最重要的是，他最近被评为《人物》杂志“全球最性感男士”。所有这些集于一身，他今天来到这里跟我们分享他是如何做到的。请欢迎DJ大AJ大正装，又名伊德瑞斯·艾尔巴。不会吧。不会吧。哇。哦，看。我当时想，等等，什么？又一个经典的贝特曼式开场白。
You guys have no guesses on that? Oh, that was so crazy. Yeah, that's crazy. That's crazy. That's crazy. That kind of being mean. How much of that was accurate, Idris? All of that, right?
你们俩对这个完全没猜到吗？哦，太疯狂了。对，太疯狂了。太疯狂了。太疯狂了。这有点刻薄。伊德瑞斯，其中有多少是真的？全都是真的，对吧？
Yeah, kind of. Well, which part? Well, you are undefeated All of it, right? Yeah, kind of. Well, which part? Well, you are undefeated in kickboxing, right? Yeah, I had one fight. Okay, well, you lose. I'm defeated. And you happen to be a pretty world famous DJ. I led with, you know, that sort of second.
对，差不多。嗯，哪一部分？嗯，你确实是全都是真的，对吧？对，差不多。嗯，哪一部分？嗯，你在自由搏击中保持不败，对吧？对，我打过一场比赛。好吧，那你输了。我被击败了。而且你恰好是一个相当世界著名的DJ。我先说了，你知道的，那算是第二点。
That I knew. Yeah, but you know that. I did not know that. I did know that. That I knew. Yeah, but it's, but you know, I did know that. I did know that, right? Yeah. Yeah. The box office stuff is true and impressive. The awards, the nominations, the land speed records.
这个我知道。对，但你知道的。我当时不知道。我其实知道这个。这个我知道。对，但它是，但你知道的，我是知道的。我是知道的，对吧？对。对。票房的事是真的，也很让人印象深刻。奖项、提名、陆地速度纪录。
All true. It didn't believe it. The land speed. It's a little embarrassing though, and I said, when you put it in the box, it was so good at every idea. You were all in one packet. It's like, it was this guy.
全都是真的。简直不敢相信。陆地速度。不过这有点尴尬，我说，当你把它写进资料里时，每个主意都太棒了。全塞进了一个包里。就像是，这就是这家伙。
It was, did you have a motor? I was like, am I? What? That's why guy. It was the guy that you ever loved. I was like, am I? What are you talking about? That's why I was using the sound effects to make flatulent sounds to make, break it up a bit. Wait, did you really race cars? Yeah, I did a documentary, which is about, you know, the need for speed and why human beings are into it.
这就是，你带发动机了吗？我当时想，我是吗？什么？这就是那个家伙。这就是你最爱的家伙。我当时想，我是吗？你在说什么？这就是为什么我用音效来制造放屁的声音，来打破一下沉闷的气氛。等等，你真的赛过车吗？对，我拍过一部纪录片，是关于，你知道的，对速度的渴望以及为什么人类会迷恋它。
And somehow it talks me into trying to break a speed record on a beach in Wales called Penn's End of the Beach. And some Malcolm Campbell did it last. And the idea is to drive the fastest in one mile. So you drive as fast as you can, you get to the beginning of the one mile and then you hit it for one mile and see how fast you get.
不知怎么的，他说服我尝试在威尔士的一个名叫彭森德的海滩上打破速度纪录。马尔科姆·坎贝尔上一次在那里打破了纪录。我们的目标是在一英里内开得最快。所以你尽可能快地开，到了那一英里的起点，然后全速开完那一英里，看看你能开多快。
Like a flying lap. Yeah. It's the most stupid thing to do it. Yeah, why would you do it on an inconsistent surface, like a sandy beach? Yeah, I don't get it. I don't know why they go to the salt flats in Utah either. Like, how about a nice piece of asphalt?
就像飞行圈一样。对。这是最愚蠢的做法。对，你为什么要在沙滩这种不平整的表面上做这种事？对，我不明白。我也不明白他们为什么要去犹他州的盐滩。比如，铺好的沥青路面不是挺好的吗？
Yeah, so what happens on a beach at 100 miles an hour, what happens is you start to hydroplane, you know, you literally start to float. Yeah, and then 180 miles. But you said, let's go ahead and go pass that and do 180. Is that right? Yeah. I've done 160, and it was really, really frightening.
对，所以在时速100英里的沙滩上会发生什么呢，你会开始水上漂，你知道的，你真的开始飘起来了。对，然后是180英里。但你却说，咱们继续加速到180英里吧。是这样吗？对。我开过160英里，真的，真的太吓人了。
Yeah. That's not fun. What were you on? I mean, in, sorry. That was me and our friend Ben Silverman on the Autobahn in Germany in a rented Porsche. The LeFrendt? Perfect guy to have you. Oh, no, wait, you know what, he was paying attention.
对。那一点都不好玩。你开的是什么车？我是说，在，抱歉。那是我和我们的朋友本·西尔弗曼在德国的高速公路上开着一辆租来的保时捷。勒弗伦特？带你去的绝佳人选。哦，不，等等，你知道吗，他当时在注意看路。
This was a different Autobahn trip. I think this might have been, was this Will Adams? It might have been Will Adams. Anyway, it's scary, but I highly recommend it. Let me just, let me just say right now for the listener who cares, are there Idris Alba right now, as a U87 microphone,
这是另一次高速公路之旅。我想这可能是，这是威尔·亚当斯吗？可能也是威尔·亚当斯。不管怎样，这很吓人，但我强烈推荐。让我现在就对关心的听众说，伊德瑞斯·艾尔巴现在用的是U87麦克风，
which is regarded as one of the, this is as a guy who does this for living, that is the Cadillac of microphones. I have one right above me here. Why aren't you using it? No, I don't have it. I've got it. Why don't we get the benefit of that?
这被认为是一支——对于一个以此为生的人来说，那是麦克风中的凯迪拉克。我正上方就有一个。你为什么不用它呢？不，我没有。我有。我们为什么不沾光用用那个呢？
I don't use it for this. I mean, he is because, I don't know about that. Yeah, because you know what, I did my own tech. Okay, so before you guys come in and grace us all, usually the tech is down for 20 minutes and it's usually someone that's in here helping that. But I chose to do it myself. I don't like that.
我不用这个。我是说，他是因为，我可不知道。对，因为你知道吗，我自己弄的技术。好吧，在你们进来给我们捧场之前，通常技术设备要调试20分钟，而且通常都是里面的某个人在帮忙。但我选择自己来。我不喜欢那样。
Showing off. Yeah, sure. And I used my SM, and then everyone's really impressed because we did the tech in five minutes. It was like, oh, what are we gonna do? And then suddenly, my interface for those who care started buzzing, so I had to change for the Cadillac of mics. Thank you for saying that.
爱出风头。对，没错。我用了我的SM，然后大家都对我们五分钟内就搞定技术设备印象深刻。当时我想，哦，我们要怎么办？然后突然，我的接口——对于关心的人来说——开始有电流声了，所以我不得不换成麦克风中的凯迪拉克。谢谢你这么说。
Oh, boy. And listen to how much nicer he sounds than you will. I know he sounds amazing. He sounds amazing. Your voice, your voice will, is out there. Thank you. I mean, I'll take the, I'll take the compliment from you because I think you've got a tremendous voice.
哦，天哪。听听他听起来比你顺耳多少，威尔。我知道他听起来太棒了。他听起来太棒了。你的声音，你的声音，威尔，真是绝了。谢谢。我是说，我接受你的赞美，因为我觉得你有一副极具磁性的嗓音。
And I'm going to start with you. Yes, he does. Idris, I came, the first time I saw, I became aware of you was in the wire. And I'm, forgive me because I'm sure that you're beyond exhausted talking about it, but it's one of the, if not the greatest television program ever made. And you in the wire were absolutely for me, just, it blew me away.
我要从你开始。是的，他确实有。伊德瑞斯，我第一次看，我开始注意到你是在《火线》里。而且，原谅我，因为我确信你已经对谈论这部剧感到精疲力竭了，但它绝对是——即使不是最伟大的，也是有史以来最伟大的电视剧之一。而你在《火线》里的表现对我来说绝对是，太震撼了。
And then to have like two seasons in and someone go, hey, you know, that guy's English. And I'm like, wait, what the fuck? Right. Are you talking about, we're obsessed with with with with Brits who can do incredible American accents. Here's the best of all time. Is it is a difficult doing the American accent? That's our that's our question.
然后拍了两季之后，有人说：“嘿，你知道吗，那家伙是个英国人。”我当时想：“等等，他妈的什么情况？”对吧？你在说什么，我们对那些能说出地道美国口音的英国演员着迷不已。这是史上最棒的。说美国口音很难吗？那是我们的，那是我们的问题。
Well, I mean, it is, yeah, it is to come straight from England and just jump into an American accent and be specific is very difficult. And, you know, I had been living in New York and New Jersey for about four years and auditioning like crazy and never getting a job. And I wasn't getting a job because my accent wasn't authentic enough.
嗯，我是说，是的，确实很难，直接从英国来到美国，一口气切换成美国口音还要表现得具体准确是非常困难的。而且，你知道的，我在纽约和新泽西住了大约四年，疯狂地试镜却从来没接到过工作。我接不到工作是因为我的口音不够地道。
And it wasn't until I really understood and lived the culture that I could sort of pull off the accent. But here's the thing, and I'm going to say this is a bit controversial because, you know, it has been over the last two decades, this big wave of English actors come to the States and do pretty good sound in American accents, you know, and nail it. And usually, there's southern accents, because southern accents and English accents are closer. So I was sort of part of the first wave of English actors doing pretty convicts in American. But if you listen to it now, you're gonna go,
直到我真正理解并融入了那种文化，我才算勉强驾驭了这种口音。但问题是，我要说的是，这有点争议，因为你知道的，在过去的二十家里，有一大批英国演员来到美国，说出听起来相当不错的美国口音，你知道的，而且拿捏得很到位。通常情况下，是南方口音，因为南方口音和英国口音更接近。所以我算是第一批说得过去美国口音的英国演员之一。但如果你现在听的话，你会觉得，
hmm, wait a second, because you're hearing things that only now, because Arias are a little more tuned to English actors doing American accents. You can hear it, I think, when I watch the Y-O-R, I watch an episode, I go, oh my God. that only now because there is a little more tune to English acts as doing American accents. You can hear it, I think, when I watch the Y-O-R, watch an episode, I go, oh my God. I don't know how I got away with that.
嗯，等一下，因为你听到了一些只有现在——因为大家的耳朵对英国演员说美国口音更熟悉了一些——你才能听出来。我想当我重温《火线》时，看其中一集，我会想：“天哪，我当年怎么蒙混过关的？”只有现在，因为大家的耳朵对英国演员说美国口音更熟悉了一些。你才能听出来，我想当我重温《火线》时，看其中一集，我会想：“天哪，我当年怎么蒙混过关的？”
I'll tell you, no, I tell you what, I just watched recently the scene where you call, I forget what season is, maybe the third season, when you call all the families, all the guys together who are the dealers, who are running Baltimore, and you're running that meeting, and you're running it like a business, it's amazing. Jason, I don't think you've seen the families, all the guys together who are the dealers, who are running Baltimore, and you're running that meeting, and you're running it like a business that's amazing. For Jason, I don't think you've seen the wire.
我告诉你，不，我告诉你，我最近刚重温了那个场景——我忘了是第几季了，可能是第三季——你把所有的家族成员，所有的毒贩头目，所有在巴尔的摩管事的家伙都召集到一起开会，你主持那个会议的样子，就像在管理一家企业一样，太棒了。杰森，我觉得你没看过——把所有的家族成员，所有的毒贩头目，所有在巴尔的摩管事的家伙都召集到一起开会，你主持那个会议的样子，就像在管理一家企业一样，太棒了。杰森，我觉得你没看过《火线》。
It's incredible. I saw the first couple of, many years ago, I got to get back in it. And you do the scene where you're like, where you got the kid in the corner, and he's on a no pad, and you go, motherfucker, are you taking notes of a criminal enterprise? But I was aware of it.
这太不可思议了。我多年前看过前几集，我得重新看起来。你演的那场戏里，你把那个小孩逼到角落里，他拿着一个记事本，你说：“他妈的，你在给犯罪集团做笔记吗？”但我知道这件事。
I'm, this is just randomly, it's within the last week that I saw that scene again and watched it and was like, again, marveling at like, God damn that is yourself, it's gonna come. Do you have a hack for the accent? Is there a certain word that drops you into the great spot you wanna be in? It's actually counting to 10.
我，这只是偶然，就在过去的一周里，我又看到了那个场景，看了一遍，然后又是那种惊叹的感觉，就像是“天哪，太厉害了”。你有什么攻克口音的秘诀吗？有没有哪个特定的词能让你瞬间进入那种你想要的状态？其实是从1到10。
Oh really? And doing, you know, the vows, AEI, OU. And cause when you do them, you know, they just, if you can flatten that out, then you can pretty much flatten a lot of different. Bet you ate is a big one, right? I ate four and a half. I ate eight.
哦，真的吗？还有发元音，A、E、I、O、U。因为当你发这些音时，你知道的，它们只是，如果你能把这些音发平稳了，那么你基本上就能把很多不同的音都发平稳。“Bet you ate”是个大难关，对吧？我吃了四个半。我吃了八个。
Well, the way we see it is to eat eight. Eight is a big. I ate. And my. I'm from Chicago when I go back. We know. Very. Bye. How did the wire come about? Now, that was Alexa, Alexa Fogel cast cast that, did you know? Yes. Yeah. Great Alexa Fogel. So she saw in you something that we all got to know. So thank you Alexa. Thank you Alexa You know when I was I got to New York New York probably in I might say 96 97 that's why I moved there And the why I wasn't until 2009 so I got cast actually in 2000 and I had been auditioning for years I did maybe lower in order. Yeah, I did one episode of
嗯，我们眼中的“吃八个”。“Eight”是个大词。我吃了。还有“my”。我来自芝加哥，当我回去的时候。我们知道。非常。拜。《火线》是怎么找上你的？那是亚历克萨·福格尔负责选角的，你知道吗？知道。是的。伟大的亚历克萨·福格尔。所以她在你身上看到了我们后来都了解到的特质。所以谢谢你，亚历克萨。谢谢你，亚历克萨。你知道，当我来到纽约，大概是在96、97年左右，这就是我搬到那里的原因。而《火线》是2009年的事，所以我实际上是在2000年被选中的，我试镜了好多年。我演过《法律与秩序》。对，我演过一集
the Lord and I did a off-board way version of Trotters and Chrysler. I think you and I were in the same episode. Well, were we? No. No, really. And I didn't couldn't get that much work. And Alex Fogo was one of the casting directors that just kept bringing me back in and saying you got something, but I love what you do. And then when I got the wire, she told me, she said, listen, when you go for this, you know, the guys are not interested in anyone
《法律与秩序》，我还演过外百老汇版的《特罗特和克莱斯勒》。我想你和我演的是同一集。真的吗？没有。真的吗？我接不到那么多工作。亚历克萨·福格尔是那些一直把我叫回去试镜的选角导演之一，她说你身上有种特质，我喜欢你的表演。后来我接到《火线》时，她告诉我，她说：“听着，你去面试的时候，你知道的，制片人们对任何不是来自巴尔的摩或东海岸的人都不感兴趣。他们甚至不考虑来自芝加哥的人。”不，这是我。他们说：“你需要走进去，假装你来自东海岸。不用表现得太具体，做好你自己的事就行。”好吧，太棒了。当时，你知道的，我已经在那里生活了，
that's not either from Baltimore or East Coast. They're not even checking for guys from Chicago. No, this was me. And they're like, you need to go in there and just pretend you're from the East Coast. Don't be specific, just do your thing. So, all right, great. And at that point, you know, I've been living now,
我几乎每天都在这么做。所以一切轻而易举，直到第四轮试镜。那儿有个制片人，是个爱尔兰人，人非常好，当然，人很好，你知道的。他把你给识破了。百分之百识破了，真的吗？滚蛋！真的，就好像第四轮回调时，我心想，我知道。他把你给识破了。百分之百识破了，真的吗？滚蛋！真的？
I was practically doing that every day. Yeah. So it was a breeze until the fourth audition. And there's a producer there, there's an Irish guy, late-grade, of course, nice thing, you know. He sniffed you out. 100% sniff, really? Out! And it really, it was like the fourth callback, I'm like, I know. He snifed you out. 100% sniff, really? Out. And really?
就像第四轮回调时，我心想，我稳了，兄弟。我稳了。只是口气有点臭。然后他问：“伊德瑞斯，你到底是哪里人？”哦哦。就是那种“你从哪儿来，你敢对我们撒谎吗，混蛋”的质问。
It was like the fourth call back. I'm like, I got this man. I've got this. Just a dirty breath. And he was like, Idris, where are you from? Uh-oh. And it was that kind of where you from, are you going to dare lie to us, motherfucker?
你打算说实话吗？是的。我是说，我真的停顿了一下，心想，哦，天哪。我想起了亚历克萨说过的话。千万别告诉他，不然我会被解雇的，巴拉巴拉。我说，听着，我来自英国，我来自伦敦东区。房间里顿时炸开了锅。他们说：“我早就说了，把钱给我。”
Are you going to say the truth? Yeah. I mean, I really pause and I was like, oh, man. And I'm thinking about what Alex has said. Please don't tell him, I'll get fired, blah, blah, blah. I said listen, I'm from England, I'm from East London. And the room exploded. They were like, I told you, I want my money.
我坐在那儿心想，发生什么事了？不会吧。太兴奋了。大卫·西蒙是什么反应？他惊呆了。他简直惊呆了。然后他们对我说：“好吧，听着。我们想让你演斯特林格·贝尔。”
I was sitting there like, what's going on? No way. And that is so excited. And what did David Simon, how did he take it? Yeah, he was flabbergasted. He was flabbergasted. And it was then they said to me, well, great, listen. We want you to play String About.
因为我本来是去试镜阿凡和巴克斯代尔的。是的。我当时想：“斯特林格·贝尔？”他在试播集里只有两句台词。我心想：“斯特林格·贝尔？”他在试播集里只有两句台词。哦，不。在试播集里。我心想：“斯特林格·贝尔，好吧。”那是哪个角色来着？
Because I was auditioning for Ava and Ava and Barclaysdale. Yeah. And I was like, String About? And he had like two lines in the pilot. I was like, string about. And he had like two lines. Oh no. In the pilot. I was like, string about, okay. Which character's that again?
他说：“你知道的，就是阿凡旁边的那个人。”我说：“好吧，好吧，到了这个时候，你知道的，哪怕是要你拍个HBO试播集然后回英国也行。”亚历克萨和我都达成一致了，我心想：“我接了，管他呢。”太好了。然后，在《火线》之后的那段时间里，是不是有一大波机会和邀约蜂拥而至，还是说发展得比较慢？
And he's like, you know, the guy just next to Ava. I'm like, okay, yeah, now at this point, you know, you even do this HBO pilot where you go back to England. We've been told between the Alex and I was like, I'll take it, whatever. Very nice. And then, so the period right after the wire, were there, was it a waterfall of opportunities and offers, or was it kind of slow growing?
你知道的，那是一段好时光。《火线》显然最初对非裔美国人社群产生了冲击。因为《火线》的发展过程。它在HBO并没有一炮而红。到了第三季，热度才达到狂热的程度。我就像个棒球运动员或说唱歌手。无论我走到哪个非裔美国人社区，我都红透半边天。他们超爱我。你就像斯特林格·贝尔。
You know, it was a good time. The wire obviously, the first audience impact was African-Americans. Because the Y grew. It wasn't hit immediately for HBO. By the third season, it was fever pitch. I was like a ball player or a rapper. Wherever I went in African-American neighborhoods, I was huge. They loved me. You're like string of bell.
所以基本上，那些蜂拥而至找我的角色基本上都是斯特林格·贝尔那种类型的，你知道的，比如黑帮分子，你知道的。我接到了所有这类角色的邀约。我和威尔·帕克合作了很多次。当然。他当时有一家制作公司，专门为非裔美国人市场拍电影。
And so basically, the roles that got offered to me in waterfall were really sort of stringer bell type characters, you know, like gangsters, you know. I just, I got offered all of that. And I worked a lot with Will Packer. Sure. At the time, had a production company, he was making films for, you films for the African American market.
他给了我在电影里的第一个大男主角。那是，我想是《福音》。你知道的，从那以后，我接演了一系列那个市场的电影，零零星星拍了一些，还有一些回英国老家拍的。但本质上，你知道的，基本上都是同一类型的角色。
And he gave me my first big lead role in a film. And it was, I think, the gospel. And, you know, from there, I could, you know, I got the string of films that were in that market, a little bit here and there, some back home in England. But essentially, you know, it was very much sort of the same type of characters.
就像在《火线》之后，甚至在演了一部大热电视剧之后，并不是所有人都会跑来找你拍戏，他们只是想看你演那种角色，尤其是斯特林格·贝尔，剧透警告。你知道的，我得强调一下。你知道的，但我懂，我能感同身受，人们总是希望你去做那件事。他们会说：“表演那个。”我懂，我以前经常遇到这种情况。
Like after the wire, after even a big TV show, it wasn't like, everyone wants to offer you jobs, it just wanted to see you play that character, especially a string of bell, no spoilers. You know, I have to stress. You know, but I get that, I relate to to that that people want you to do the thing. They're like, do the thing. And I get I used to get that a lot.
就像人们会说：“像个傻子一样表演。更多。我们想看你一直像个傻子一样表演。”他们根本没看过《发展受阻》。他们只是看到我的脸。觉得他挺笨的。对，他们只是觉得：蠢脸。
We're like, you know, act like an idiot. More. We want to see you act like an idiot all the time. And they'd never seen a rest of development. They were just like, they just see my face. He's pretty dumb. Yeah, they were just like, stupid face.
然后他们就会说：当个大笨蛋。表现得比你本身更笨。更笨。还要更笨。这方面我可是从威尔那儿接手的。所以，你一直在当DJ吗？所以你对音乐情有独钟。我太喜欢了。你以前、期间以及现在都一直在玩音乐、当DJ，对吧？就像你从未停下过脚步。跟我们聊聊这个，以及你对音乐的热情是怎么来的。你知道的，我14岁时就决定我真的想成为一名演员。但那时，我其实已经在当DJ了，大概从7岁左右开始。我叔叔是个DJ，我经常跟他一起去打碟。
And they were like, be dumb dummy. Be even dumber than you are. Even dumber. even dumber. Even then I took that over from well. So now are you DJing the whole time? So you're your your into music. I love this. You're playing playing music as well as DJing before, during, and currently, right? Like you've never stopped. Tell us about that and where that music passion came from. And you know, I was 14 when I decided I really want to become an actor. But at that point, I had been DJ and you know, pretty much like 70. Like my uncle was a DJ and I used to DJ with him.
他是，你知道的，非洲人，非洲婚礼，非洲基督徒，基督徒。这是在哪儿？英国的哪个部分？我来自伦敦东区，但伦敦的西非人社区分布比较广，南伦敦、东区都有。所以我经常跟着我叔叔去打碟，基本上，每当他喝得太醉无法坚持时，那个DJ说，我就想上台，帮他把剩下的部分完成。
He's, you know, African man, African weddings, African Christians, Christian. And where is this? what part of England? So I'm from East London, but the community of West Africans in London was sort of spread out South London, East London. So I used to go with my uncle and DJ, and basically, whenever he got too drunk to finish, the DJ said, I wanted to be up there, just trying to finish up for him.
你多大年纪开始帮着收尾的？老兄，我大约12岁左右开始，就在那儿帮他收尾。你多大年纪开始帮着收尾的？老兄，我大约12岁左右开始，你知道的，一直持续到十几岁，然后站在一个箱子上。站在一个箱子上。其实它挺高的。这是一个热门话题。所以，你知道的，我13岁的时候就长胡子了。所以人们以为我是个……
And how old are you finishing up? Dude, I started around, I was about 12, there just trying to finish up for you. And how old are you finishing up? Dude, I started around 12 and you know, way into my teens and then standing on a box. Standing on a box. Actually, it was tall. It was a big hit. So, you know, and I had a beard by the time I was 13. So people just thought I was a...
哇。肖恩·蒂尔。肖恩，你带胡子去毕业舞会了吧？对啊。嘿，曾——曾——所以当——所以你14岁的时候，你带着胡子去参加毕业舞会了吧？对啊。嘿，嗯，曾——曾——所以当——所以你14岁的时候，你只是——你刚刚比我慢了两秒钟。你决定你——我听到一半才反应过来。
Wow. Sean Till. Sean, you took a beard to prom, right? Yep. Hey, did, did. So when, so you were 14, you took a beer to, to prom, right? Yep. Hey, um, did, did. So when, so you were 14, you just, you just, I was like two seconds behind you and that. You decided you, I caught it halfway through, too.
我知道。对。所以，所以你14岁在当DJ，然后你就在想，什么？你是在看电视，还是在学校上戏剧课，是什么让你觉得：是的，我想做那个？我上的是一所男校，三一男校。你知道的，这所学校相当严厉，你知道的，主要注重体育和学术。
Yeah, I know. Yeah. So, so you're 14, you're DJing, and then you're like, what? You're like watching TV, or you're doing, you're taking drama at school, or what's going on that you go like, yeah, I want to do that I went to a boy school Trinity boys and You know this school was pretty rough and you know, it was really sort of sports and academia
但戏剧——我很擅长体育。学术也还行，但戏剧。我简直棒极了。对，我的戏剧老师麦克菲小姐。她觉得我极具天赋。体育还行，学术也行，但戏剧，我简直棒极了。我的戏剧老师麦克菲小姐，她觉得我很有才华，觉得我是块料。在一所男校里，大家上戏剧课都只是胡闹和找乐子，对吧？
But drama I was good at sports. It's okay with academia, but drama. I was awesome Yeah, and my drama teacher miss McFee. She just thought I was very talented sports. Okay, Vacademia, but drama, I was awesome at. And my drama teacher, Miss McFee, she just thought I was very talented, then she thought there's something there. And in a boy's school, everyone just uses drama, drama class to just piss about and have fun, right?
但我可不搞那一套。我是认真的，我心想：我是真的超级喜欢做这个。当我要面临期末考试和所有事情的时候，她问我：“伊德瑞斯，你是认真的吗？”当时我说：“不，我要当个广播DJ。我想在广播里放音乐。那就是我想做的。”她说：“好吧，这挺好的，但你不应该放弃表演。你很有天赋。”你知道我后来怎么做的吗？去年，我说：“其实，老师，我打算——好吧，告诉我该怎么做。我照做就是了。”所以她帮我报名了
But I do that shit. Seriously, I was like, I really love doing this. And she, when I was time to do my finals exams and everything, she was like, Idris, are you serious about it? At that time, I was like, no, I'm going to be a radio DJ. I wanted to play music on the radio. That's what I wanted to do. She's like, okay, that's good, but you should not give up on acting. You're very good. And you know what I did? And then last year, I said, actually, miss, I'm going to, all right, tell me what to do. And I'll do it. So she enrolled me in
下一阶段的学习，那是一个专门针对表演艺术的大学课程。我学了两年。到了那个时候，你知道的，我刚好18岁，19岁就找到了第一份工作。哇。你还记得高中时演过的一些作品吗？比如你演过所有高中都会演的经典戏剧和音乐剧吗？没有，没有。我的……戏剧课更多是即兴表演，你知道的，还有很多尼尔·西蒙的作品。对，这就是我要演的。我在《人鼠之间》里演过莱尼。你知道那两部戏吗，比如《笨蛋》或者《书呆子》？你知道这两部戏吗？
the next stage, which was a college course that was specific about performing arts. I did that for two years. And then at that point, you know, I literally was 18 years old and I got my first job at 19. Wow. Do you remember some of the stuff you were in high school? Like were you in like classic plays and musicals that all high schools do? No, no. The... I draw my classes was more improvisational, you know, and a lot of Neil Simon. Yeah, that's the thing I'll do. I did play Lenny in Of My Semendo. Do you know the plays, the Forner or the Nerd? Do you know those two plays?
我不知道。非常感谢……为什么，肖恩，你什么意思？嘿，那是两部非常、非常、非常、非常火爆的高中戏剧，甚至影响深远，他们——因为杰森说的是尼尔·西蒙，他本该成为下一个尼尔·西蒙，拉里·舒写作了那些戏剧，它们获得了巨大的成功。而且他妈妈还是我高中的西班牙语老师。哦，原来如此。
I don't know. Thanks so much for 7. Why, Sean, what was your point? Hey, it was those were those are two very very very very huge popular plays for high school well and beyond and they they guy because Jason said Neil Simon he was supposed to be like the next Neil Simon Larry Schoo wrote those plays and there are massively huge Successes and his mom was my Spanish teacher in high school. Oh, so.
哦，那太棒了。哦，是的。哦，是的。是的。抱歉，当你这么说的时候，好吧，对，好吧。但对，你的西班牙语老师是他妈妈，对，绝对是的。谢谢你，肖恩。我只想聊聊《普罗米修斯》。
Oh, that's the best. Oh, yes. Oh, yes. Yes. Sorry, when you said, OK, yes, OK. But yeah, your Spanish teacher is mom, yeah, for sure. Thanks, Sean. All I want to talk about is Prometheus.
好吧，请便。我们马上会聊到那个。不，我们会聊到的。我们只是，我们正在一点点剖析他的人生。嘿，听着，19岁的第一份工作，第一份像样的、有报酬的专业工作？是的，第一份工作其实是一个关于自行车被偷的疯狂小广告，我扮演一个大喊“我的自行车被偷了”的家伙，跑上一座山，演了一小段。然后我接了一部电视剧，是一部儿童电视剧。
OK, go ahead. We're going to get to that. No, we're getting there. We're just, we're inching our ways through his life. Hey, listen, first job at 19, first like professional job, like getting paid. Yes, it was, first job was actually this little crazy commercial about getting your bike stolen and I played a guy to go, my bike stolen and run up a hill and did a bit of acting. And then I got a TV show, which was a kids TV show.
我当时19岁，但演的是一个16岁的角色。天哪。我是搞笑担当。我只是个子长得有点大，不适合上学。但是，但是，你知道的，我想要回到正题，你知道的，当谈到谁写了什么、谁演了什么的时候，我真的是最烂的——你会和杰森很谈得来的。对，没错，他什么都不记得。对，我是杰森。
I was 19, but I was playing someone that was 16. Oh boy. I was part of the gag. I was just a bit big for school. But yeah, but you know, I wanted to go back, you know, I'm really the worst guy when it comes to like, who wrote what, what was in what like, you know, you'll get along with Jason really well. Yeah, no, he doesn't remember anything. Yeah, I'm Jason.
你刚刚做了什么？杰森，你今天早上吃什么了？嗯，我还在从牙缝里剔呢。所以这挺有用的。是一整碗燕麦片。他也是什么都不记得。我很感激这一点。不过听着，这个播客叫Smartless。
What did you do this one? What do you, what do you have for breakfast this morning Jason? Well, I'm still sort of picking it out of my teeth. So that's helpful. It's a whole get a oatmeal. He doesn't remember shit either. I appreciate that. But listen, the podcast is called Smartless.
我是冲着Less来的。没错。这就是我们来的目的。总会有Less。欢迎来到这个节目。我们马上回来。《Smartless》由BetterHelp赞助。听着，我有过人生的高谷，也有过低谷，有过清醒的时刻，
I came for the less. Yeah, sure. That's why there for the less. Yeah, sure. That's why we're the way to. There's always less. Welcome to the party. And we will be right back. Smartless is sponsored by BetterHelp. Now, I have had ups, I've had downs, I've had clarity,
也有过迷茫的时候。没有什么比和生活中的亲近之人倾诉更有帮助了。如果那个人不在身边，有时候找个治疗师也是个不错的选择，效果一直很好。现在，没有什么比一个只需通过电话就能联系到的治疗师更方便的了，对吧？有时在生活中我们会面临艰难的选择，前方的道路并不总是清晰的。你有各种各样的选择。你不确定该选哪一个，你知道吗？无论你是在处理关于职业、人际关系还是其他任何事情的决定，
I've had confusion. Nothing has been more helpful than talking about it with somebody close in my life. And if that person's not around, sometimes a therapist has been and it's been great. Now, nothing could be more convenient than a therapist that's at the other end of a phone, right? Sometimes in life we're faced with tough choices and the path forward isn't always clear. You've got a bunch of different options. You're not sure which one to pick, you know? With your dealing with decisions around career, relationships or anything else,
心理咨询都能在你导航人生时，帮你与内心真正渴望的东西保持连结。这样你就能充满自信和激情地向前迈进。相信自己能够做出符合价值观的决定就像任何事情一样，你练习得越多，就会变得越容易。所以相信我，朋友们，和专业人士聊聊真的很有帮助。如果你正在考虑开始心理咨询，
therapy helps you stay connected to what you really want while you navigate life. So you can move forward with confidence and excitement. Trusting yourself to make decisions that align with your values is like anything, the more you practice it, the easier it gets. So trust me friends, talk to a professional really helps. If you're thinking of starting therapy,
不妨试试BetterHelp。它完全在网上进行，旨在提供便捷、灵活的服务，并完美契合你的时间安排。所以，我刚才可能说过，治疗师就在电话的另一端，但它也可以在你的电脑的另一端。只需填写一份简单的问卷，就能与获得执照的治疗师进行匹配，并且可以随时免费更换治疗师。让心理咨询成为你的
give better help a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. So now I may have said, therapists is on the other end of the phone, but it can be at the other end of your computer too. So just feel out of brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists at any time for no additional charge. Let therapy be your
人生指南，就用BetterHelp。今天就访问betterhelp.com/smartless，首月即可享受九折优惠。网址是betterhelp.com/smartless。help, at kelp.com/smartless。《Smartless》得到了Eight Sleep的支持。我们当然得到了支持。Eight Sleep，他们非常支持我们，对吧？我是说，听着，你知道温度是改善睡眠质量最重要的因素之一吗，肖恩？我有一个Eight Sleep。
map with better help. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartless today to get 10% off your first month. That's better help aglp.com slash smartless. help, at kelp.com slash smartless. Smartless gets support from eight sleep. We sure do. That eight sleep, they're very supportive, right? I mean, look, did you know that temperature is one of the most important factors in improving your sleep quality, Sean? I have an eight sleep.
科学已经证明，你的体温在睡眠的早期和中期实际上需要下降，而在早晨需要上升，这样你才能更快入睡并获得更多深度睡眠。Eight Sleep的智能床罩可以像床单一样套在任何床垫上。智能床罩会根据你和你伴侣的个性化需求，自动调整床铺两侧的温度，从而改善你的睡眠。它可以降温、升温，并根据你的睡眠阶段以及你所处的环境进行调整。
And science has shown that your body temperature actually needs to drop in the early and middle part of your sleep and rise in the morning so that you can fall asleep fast and get more deep sleep. The pod cover by 8-sleep fits on any bed like a fitted sheet. The pod cover will improve your sleep by automatically adjusting the temperature on each side of the bed based on you and your partners individual needs. It can cool down and warm up and adjusts based on the bed based on you and your partners, individual needs. It can cool down and warm up, and adjust based on the phases of your sleep and the environment that you are in.
我和我妻子睡觉时喜欢的温度是不一样的。而且有时每天都在变。我想开冷气，有时她想开，所以我想要，有时她想要，有了Eight Sleep，有了智能床罩，这再也不是个问题了。不，这太简单了。
My wife and I like temperatures different when we're sleeping. And that changes from day to day, sometimes. I want to call it, sometimes she wants to go, so I want to, sometimes she wants to, with the aid sleep, with the pod cover, there's not a problem anymore. No, it's easy.
不，确实如此。我睡觉非常——我喜欢在非常凉爽的环境下睡觉。在生活中，我比较怕冷，我喜欢暖和，但在晚上，不知怎的，我会变得非常、非常热。所以这简直是完美的东西。它会为我自动调节，还能追踪诸如快速眼动睡眠、你什么时候起床、什么时候上床睡觉等等各种数据。
No, that's right. I sleep very, like, I like to sleep really cool. In life, I run cold, I like to be warm, but at night, for some reason, I get real, real hot. So this is the perfect thing. It figures it out for me, and it tracks like REM sleep, and when you get up, and when you go to bed, and blah, blah, blah, blah, all that kind of stuff.
说真的，正如我们所说，虽然温度是最大的改变者，但智能床罩还有其他令人惊叹的功能。例如，多亏了智能床罩的睡眠和健康追踪功能，你每天早晨都能收到一份个性化的睡眠报告，其中包含关于深夜锻炼或咖啡因等特定行为如何影响你的睡眠和整体健康的洞察。Eight Sleep，他们每天早晨都关爱你，对吧？他们确实如此，现在就投资你应得的优质睡眠，选择Eight Sleep智能床罩吧。
Seriously, as we were saying, while temperature is the biggest game changer the pod cover has other amazing features. For example, thanks to the pod sleep and health tracking you can wake up to a personalized sleep report for you each morning that offers insights on how certain behaviors like late night exercise or caffeine impact your sleep and overall health. Eight sleep they love you every morning right? They do and not right now invest in the rest you deserve with the eight sleep pod. Go to eightsleep.com slash smart list and save $150 on the pod cover by eight sleep.
访问eightsleep.com/smartless，购买Eight Sleep智能床罩即可节省150美元。这是你能找到的最好的优惠了，各位，但你必须访问eightsleep.com/smartless才能享受150美元的优惠。Eight Sleep目前在美國、加拿大、英國、歐盟部分國家和澳大利亞發貨。《Smartless》由SmartWater赞助。觉得怎么样？是的，这似乎早就该有了。这真是一个天然的契合，欢迎SmartWater。很高兴有你加入。
That's the best offer you're going to find folks, but you must visit eightsleep.com slash smart list for your $150 off. Eight sleep currently ships within the USA, Canada, the UK, select countries in the EU and Australia. SmartLess is sponsored by SmartWater. Now how about that? Yeah, it seems like this is very overdue. The natural tie-in, welcome smart water. It's nice to have you.
很高兴有你加入。你知道的，很高兴有你加入，因为每当我演百老汇的时候——也就是现在——我总是处于严重脱水状态，非常严重，我所做的是，我实际上在后台常备SmartWater，只要一走下舞台，我就会狂饮，我疯狂地喝，因为我流了太多汗。我需要，你知道的。
And it is nice to have you. And you know, it's nice to have you because whenever I'm doing Broadway, which is right now, I'm constantly dehydrated, constantly, and I do what I do is I actually do keep smart water backstage, and I drink it any time I walk off stage, I pound it, I pound it, because I'm sweating so much. And I need to, you know.
你知道的，夏天很热，对吧？你在夏天怎么降暑？你跳进游泳池，拿水管冲别人，有时你向他们扔水气球，你知道的，你知道的，夏天很热，对吧？你在夏天怎么降暑？你跳进游泳池，拿水管冲别人，有时你向他们扔水气球，你知道的？也许我——也许我应该开始往SmartWater的水气球里灌水，但太多了。这是个好主意。然后当它们在你脸上炸开时，你直接喝掉就行了。
You know, in the summer, it's hot, right? And how do you cool down on the summer? You jump in the pool, you shoot the hose on somebody, sometimes you throw water balloons at them, you know, you know, in the summer, it's hot, right? And how do you cool down on the summer? You jump in the pool, you shoot the hose on somebody, sometimes you throw water balloons at them, you know? Like maybe you maybe I should start filling a water balloon to smart water, but so much. That's a good idea. Then when they explode in your face, you just drink them.
在我们的播客节目中，我们是Smartless，但绝不少了SmartWater。哦，水是100%蒸汽蒸馏的，口感纯净清脆。它酸碱平衡，并添加了电解质以提升口感。你能说也许SmartWater在你的托尼奖得奖中发挥了一部分作用吗？我发现确实如此。既然如此，那你为什么不在
Here on the podcast, we are smartless, but not smart water less. Oh, water is 100% vapor distilled with a pure crisp taste. It's pH balance and offers added electrolytes for taste. Could you say that maybe smart waters are partly responsible for your Tony win? I found so. As thousand, well, why don't you think them when you
发表获奖感言时感谢它们呢？你没在我的梦里听到吗？我想你在理想的领奖台上是不会感谢它们的。感谢SmartWater成就了我的托尼奖。这里写着我们不能说SmartWater能让你变得更聪明，但我们可以说它适合你在听最喜欢的播客时细细品味，当然了，喝SmartWater，保持聪明。现在回到节目中。
accept your job? Did you not hear it in my sleep? I don't think you think them when you are in an ideal podium. Thanks smart water for my Tony. And it says here we're not allowed to say the smart water makes you smarter, but we can say it's for sip and while you're listening to your favorite podcast of course, keep it smart with smart water. And now back to the show.
现在，关于——在我们还在聊DJ的话题时，告诉我们吧。难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道你，难道 you up and he was like, yeah, I was like, yeah. And then, you know, at one point, he was like, this man, I'm getting married. I was like, yo, that's amazing.
Now what about tell us while we're still on the DJ thing. Didn't you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did
那么，趁我们还在聊DJ的事，你能不能告诉我们，你是不是，是不是，是不是……
you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did up and he was like, yeah, I was like, yeah. And then, you know, at one point, he was like, this man, I'm getting married. I was like, yo, that's amazing.
是不是，最后他提起了，然后他就说，对啊，我也说，对啊。然后呢，你知道的，有一次他说，兄弟，我要结婚了。我说，哇，太棒了。
What is this? I went to the DJ. And this is, you know, we're just at this club about your card. No, you had my number. You made a request. I was like, I don't take, oh, hey, man, that's it. Now, you've got this thing on Apple TV plus called hijack. This is an intense, I'm
这是什么？我去找了DJ。这就是，你知道的，我们当时就在那个俱乐部讨论你的卡片。不，你记着我的号。你提了要求。我当时想，我不接受，哦，嘿，老兄，就是这样。现在，你在Apple TV plus上有一部叫《劫机七小时》的剧。这是一部紧张的，我
going to guess it takes place on a plane a little bit. Yes. What gave it away for you? I've just done a little bit of research. Now, Sean would like to know, do you have any crazy stories on an airplane? He's basically good for any of the junky questions that you're I love. Those are my favorite. Because I have a great, I have a great plane story.
猜它主要发生在飞机上，对吧？是的。你是怎么看出来的？我刚刚做了一点研究。现在，肖恩想知道，你们在飞机上有过什么疯狂的故事吗？他基本上对你们提的所有那些乱七八糟的问题都来者不拒。我喜欢。那些是我的最爱。因为我有一个很棒的，我有一个很棒的飞机故事。
Tell me. Yeah, let's do it. Sean, let's do it. I just can't hold on one second. I have a great plane star. Tell me. Yeah, my friend, please. Let's hear Sean. Let's hear Sean.
跟我讲讲。好吧，我们开始吧。肖恩，我们开始吧。我只是，等一下。我有一个很棒的飞机故事。跟我讲讲。好吧，我的朋友，请吧。让我们听听肖恩的。让我们听听肖恩的。
Yeah, Idris, can you hold on one second? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Sean. Yeah. This is your time. Okay.
好吧，伊德瑞斯，你能等一下吗？好吧。好吧。好吧。肖恩。好吧。这是你的时间。好吧。
By the way, good to have you. It might be good. It might be my inspired. It might be good to have you. It might be my inspired. All of you to tell your airplane stories, me and my friend, Reina, you all know Reina. We were going to England for the first time. I was going to London for the first time in my life and we got on what's the brand, who
顺便说一句，很高兴你能来。这可能挺好。这可能给了我灵感。这可能挺好，能让你把你的飞机故事说出来，我和我的朋友雷娜，你们都认识雷娜。我们第一次去英国。我这辈子第一次去伦敦，我们坐的是什么牌子，谁
flies? British Airways. So we're in first class, we're like oh my god, it's like first class, like a hotel, right? So we're like let's get on the time difference right away. So we took two ambien and we're drinking wine, we just can't go to sleep because we're so excited that we're in first class on the way to England for the first time. And everybody in the cabin was completely flat bed sleeping, right? So I went around and came mere centimeters from everybody's mouth as they were sleeping
飞的？英国航空。所以我们在头等舱，我们当时想，哦，天哪，这简直是头等舱，就像一家酒店，对吧？所以我们想，得马上调整时差。于是我们吃了两片安眠药，喝着酒，结果我们太兴奋了，根本睡不着，因为我们第一次坐头等舱去英国。客舱里的每个人都在完全放平的床上睡觉，对吧？所以我到处走，离每个人的嘴只有几厘米远，当时他们正在睡觉
and I went and kissed every single passenger on air kissing. Air kissing. We were crying. Drunk, drunk, drunk, booze, and booze. And they're like, yeah. Was there, was there a soulful? If anybody would have woken up, cell phone footage of this event?
然后我走过去，亲吻了每一个乘客，隔空亲吻。隔空亲吻。我们都哭了。喝醉了，喝醉了，喝醉了，酒，还有酒。他们就说，是的。有没有，有没有深情地？如果有人醒了，有这件事情的手机录像吗？
No, of course, cell phones. Yeah. Oh, man, boy. Yeah. Yeah, but, you know, honestly, if you're in first class or if there's anyone that's not been in first class, first class, you know, you're, if you have been and you happen to be up, you're just really curious to who else is in here. And I do walk around and just like, yeah, do do do do do do do do do.
没有，当然没有手机。是啊。哦，天哪，老兄。是啊。是啊，但是，你知道，老实说，如果你在头等舱，或者如果有谁没坐过头等舱，头等舱，你知道的，如果你坐过，而且碰巧还醒着，你其实只是很好奇这里面还有谁。我确实四处走动，然后就像，耶，嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟。
Now, what do you guys have a fix for? I don't like to fall asleep on airplanes, although I do a lot, because you can't help but have your jaw fall open while you're sleeping because you're sitting up, right? Right. Right. So I see some people, I've seen some people, yeah, well, it's just not a great look. I've seen some people sleep with like a sweater over their fat over their head or something over their fat heads, over their fat heads. Or maybe is that what those little neck pillows are for so it can kind of keep your jaw shut?
现在，你们有什么解决办法吗？我不太喜欢在飞机上睡着，虽然我经常睡着，因为你坐着的时候，睡觉时会不由自主地把嘴巴张得老大，对吧？对的。对的。所以我看到有些人，我看到有些人，好吧，这看起来确实不太好看。我看到有些人睡觉时把毛衣盖在脸、头上，或者在他们胖乎乎的头上顶着什么东西，在他们胖乎乎的头上。或者也许那些小颈枕就是用来稍微闭住你的嘴的？
A little bit? No. First of all, first of all, this is, this is, this is, sorry, it just can you hold on one more second. There's, there's no way. Who are you worried about seeing your jaw open? Distortus on your fucking private plane? Wait, I don't fly private.
有一点吗？没有。首先，首先，这是，这是，这是，抱歉，伊德瑞斯，你能再等一秒钟吗。不可能。你在担心谁看到你张着嘴？在你的屁大点儿私人飞机上摆姿态吗？等等，我不坐私人飞机。
Anybody with a cell phone, you know, it would be, it would be, it would be, it would be, it would be, the pilot on his way back to used the bathroom when it just, you're the only passenger. What are you talking about? Nice try celebrities, they're just like us. No, they're not. And what goes on up there in the front of the plane?
任何拿着手机的人，你知道的，这会是，这会是，这会是，这会是，这会是，飞行员在往回走去上厕所的时候，正好你是唯一的乘客。你在说什么？好样的，明星们，他们和我们一样。不，他们才不一样。飞机前舱里到底在发生什么？
Oh, like it's like they're eating great. Anyway. Do you guys do you see well in the plane, Interest? Are you a good plane sleeper? Uh, yeah, pretty decent. And I usually try, I do fall asleep in that time period between, you know, sitting down and taking off. Oh, yeah.
哦，感觉他们吃得太好了。不管怎样。你们在飞机上睡得好吗，伊德瑞斯？你是个在飞机上睡得好的人吗？呃，是的，还算凑合。我通常会尽量，我确实会在坐下来和起飞之间的那段里睡着。哦，是的。
So there's probably a bunch of pictures of me with my jaw open. Yeah. I one time I was flying over. It's flying from Newark to Europe. And they took an ambient years ago. Took an ambient. As soon as we start taxing, I'm like, here we go.
所以可能有很多我张着嘴的照片。Yeah.我曾经有一次飞越。从纽瓦克飞往欧洲。他们几年前吃了一片安眠药。吃了一片安眠药。我们一开始滑行，我就想，开始了。
Put the ambient in because I don't want to, you know, we haven't moved from the gate yet. I don't want to get caught in that thing of like something's wrong. And then now you're on ambient. We take off, the seat won't go back. It's locked. It's broken. So I like, ding, ding, and I get the flat.
把安眠药吃了，因为我不想，你知道的，我们还没离开登机口呢。我可不想碰上那种出了什么问题的情况。然后现在你已经吃了安眠药了。我们起飞了，座椅放不下去。它卡住了。它坏了。所以我按了，叮，叮，然后我找了个空乘。
She comes to help me. And these two, it was a Scandinavian. These two Scandinavian flat intent. They came in, they just like took my seat apart and manually put it back. Meanwhile, I'm in the aisle. I'm safe. And the ambience kicking in and I feel fucking crazy.
她来帮我。这两位，那是一个斯堪的纳维亚航班。这两位斯堪的纳维亚空乘。他们走过来，直接把我的座椅拆开，然后手动把它装回去了。与此同时，我正站在过道里。我很安全。而且安眠药开始起效了，我觉得自己他妈的像个疯子。
Yeah. I'm like, have you ever been awake on ambient before? It's a nightmare. It's not fun. Well, listen, as I don't condone or take drugs, and I, when you say an ambient, I kept thinking you were saying, amblin' as in. Yeah. This is Spielberg. Yeah, just a little bit that you
是啊。我就想，你以前在吃安眠药的时候清醒过吗？那简直是个噩梦。一点也不好玩。好吧，听着，我不纵容也不服用药物，而且我，当你提到安眠药（Ambien）时，我一直以为你在说安培林（Amblin），也就是。是的。这是斯皮尔伯格的。是的，就那么一点点你
Yeah, yeah, yeah, so I watch I watch all the amazes and those Ambien has produced incredible bad How old were you when you came from England to the States? I was How old were you when you came from England to the States? I was 27 probably. 27. And dumb dumb question. Yeah. Because I'm obsessed with people's first impressions
对，对，对，所以我看，我看所有的安培林电影，那些安眠药制作了令人难以置信的糟糕。你从英国来美国时多大？我当时是。你从英国来美国时多大？我大概27岁。27岁。还有个愚蠢的问题。是的。因为我迷恋人们对美国的
of the United States. What were the first things they were like, yeah, this is fucking a weird being. You go right into New York? I went straight into New York. When I moved to New York, I was 27. When the first time I got to New York was 20. I was 20 years old.
第一印象。你们当时觉得第一批事情是什么，就觉得，这他妈太诡异了。你直接去了纽约吗？我直接去了纽约。我搬到纽约时27岁。我第一次到纽约时20岁。我当时20岁。
And I had just finished this two-year performing arts course doing everything. And in that time period, I learned about the Lee Strasbourg institution that lived in 14th Street from New York. And I decided to go to school. Yep. The abstracts at 10th York, and I decided to go there. And I sort of lived in New York for six weeks, practically in a YMCA around 14th Street.
我刚刚完成了一个两年的表演艺术课程，什么都学。在那段时间里，我了解到了李·斯特拉斯伯格学院，它就在纽约的第14街。我决定去那儿上学。是的。纽约的斯特拉斯伯格学院，我决定去那儿。我差不多在纽约住了六周，基本上就住在第14街附近的基督教青年会（YMCA）。
In 1990? Yep, 91, roughly. How in the world? Idris, I was there at that same time. Serious? At the school, at least, at the Strasper? At the least, Strasper, yeah. No way.
1990年？对，91年，差不多吧。这怎么可能？伊德瑞斯，我当时也在那儿。真的吗？在学校里，在斯特拉斯伯格？在斯特拉斯伯格，对。不可能。
Yeah. Are you serious? I swear to God. Wow. Did you guys see each other clearly? You know what? His thing, his thing. I didn't realize that you needed a visa to get in.
真的吗？我发誓。哇。你们当时见过面吗？你知道吗？他的事，他的事。我当时不知道进去需要签证。
So I had gone over there. I was thinking I could just feel like, hey, I'm here, you might have just paying them. Like, nobody, you need a visa, student visa to be here. So I ended up staying in New York for six weeks. And the first thing that struck me, wasn't weird. It was just that it's food obsessed, like food everywhere. Like, you know, nice to go to a place called the coffee shop,
所以我去了那里。我以为我只要到那儿就行了，就像，嘿，我到了，我可能付过钱了。就像，没有人，你需要学生签证才能留在这里。所以我最后在纽约呆了六周。第一件让我震惊的事，并不觉得怪异。只是觉得那里对食物太痴迷了，到处都是食物。就像，你知道的，喜欢去一个叫“咖啡馆”的地方，
which is a little small. Oh yeah. It seems like it's great, right? You remember this one? Yeah. Right across the unit. It's great. Yeah.
那是个很小的地方。哦，是的。听起来挺棒的，对吧？你还记得这个吗？是的。就在那个大学对面。挺棒的。是的。
And the food was amazing, you know, and for no money, too, it's just like, wow, I was just like, this is crazy. So when you go back to England now, do you notice a difference in the food? Like, are you like, are you miss American food? Or no?
而且食物太棒了，你知道的，而且花不了多少钱，就是那种，哇，我当时就想，这太疯狂了。所以你现在回英国时，会觉得食物有什么不同吗？比如，你会像，你会想念美国食物吗？还是不会？
No, I lived in America for 16 years and coming back to England. I guess the variety is just not as good. You know what I mean? The variety in America was just like, yeah, there's so much of it. There's so much, but there's almost, it's an interesting point.
不，我在美国住了16年，回到英国后。我猜花样就是没那么好。你知道我的意思吗？美国的种类就是让人觉得，哇，有那么多。选择太多了，但几乎可以说是，这是一个有趣的点。
It is, we are sort of food obsessed in that sort of, it's, but it's very, it's a very American idea, right? It's just like more, more, more, bigger, more come. And so they're constantly advertising, got it in your face and stuff, and it's not like that. Yeah. Yeah. It's very, if you like food, it's great, because the variety
确实，我们对食物确实有一种痴迷，那种，但是这非常美国化，对吧？就像是，更多，更多，更多，更大，更多。所以他们一直在做广告，让你天天看到诸如此类的东西，这里可不是这样。是的。是的。如果你喜欢食物，这里很棒，因为选择
is there. Yeah. There's like seven different sizes of cheese it. Ox, I always get the biggest one. Is there, Sean? Yeah.'s there. Yeah, there's like seven different sizes of cheeset boxes. I was getting the biggest one. Is there Sean? Yeah. Are there? Yeah.
都在那儿。是的。有大概七种不同尺寸的芝士脆饼（Cheez-It）。盒装的，我总是买最大的。有吗，肖恩？是的。有吗？是的，有大概七种不同尺寸的芝士脆饼盒子。我总是买最大的。有吗，肖恩？是的。有吗？是的。
What's it? What's it? Cheeset. There's some little colon cement. Hey, Idris, are you in England now? I am. I'm in London. All right.
什么？什么？芝士脆饼。有一些小小的水泥柱。嘿，伊德瑞斯，你现在在英国吗？是的。我在伦敦。好的。
Now, do you love going back there and working like Luther, you guys shot in English? Okay. Well, I want to get into Luther. When did you do the first series of Luther? Fuck, dude. Luther is so excellent. When was that first series, man? First series was in 2011, was 2011, roughly. And this was at the sort of end of my American journey. Like, you know, I'd been there for 16 years, roughly, about that point. And I was just seeing this glass ceiling hit me at the head, you know, I had worked, was, you know, a door respected.
现在，你喜欢回去拍戏吗，比如《路德》，你们是在英国拍的吗？好的。好吧，我想聊聊《路德》。你是什么时候拍第一季《路德》的？操，老兄。《路德》太棒了。那是哪一年拍的第一季，老兄？第一季是在2011年，大约是2011年。这大概是我美国之旅的尾声。就像，你知道的，我在那里呆了大约16年，差不多到了那个时候。我当时看到天花板正压在我的头上，你知道的，我工作过，是，你知道的，备受尊敬的。
I love America. I had a great time. I lived in LA. I lived in Miami. I lived in Miami, I lived in Atlanta, I lived everywhere, and I just could see that actually there was something missing in my career that I maybe if I went home I could, you know, sort of patch up and that was theatre. I wanted to go back to the theatre, I didn't want to do it in New York, I wanted to go back to the theatre.
我爱美国。我过得很开心。我住在洛杉矶。我住在迈阿密。我住在迈阿密，我住在亚特兰大，我住过很多地方，我只是能看出，实际上我的职业生涯中缺少了一些东西，如果我回家的话，也许我可以，你知道的，去弥补一下，那就是戏剧。我想回到戏剧界，我不想在纽约做这个，我想回到戏剧界。
And while that was happening, while I was making that decision, then the script came along and it was it was nootha. And I was like, you know, the BBC, first of all, you know, being in a lead on the BBC was like a big deal. And I hadn't ever done that in my career because I spent most of it in England. I mean, America. So it was a really big deal to be offered a lead role in a big six-part drama about detective. You know what I mean? It was literally that, oh, this is great. I'll take this. And that was the beginning of the second half of my career, I guess, you know, at that point.
正当这一切发生的时候，正当我做出那个决定的时候，剧本出现了，那就是《路德》。我当时想，你知道的，BBC，首先，你知道的，在BBC担任主演是一件大事。而且我在自己的职业生涯中从来没有做过那种事，因为我大部分时间都在英国度过。我是说，美国。所以，能在一个关于侦探的大型六集剧集中获得一个主角，真的是一件大事。你知道我的意思吗？真的就是那样，哦，这太棒了。我接了。我想，那是我职业生涯第二半程的开始吧，你知道的，就在那个时候。
That was, I mean, for me, that was one of those. And I was already a big fan of yours. So I was in when I saw you that you were doing this thing. I wanted to watch it. And then watching it, it was so kind of a so blown away but and also you're doing it with the great Paul McGann as well, who I adore from my favorite film of all time, of course, is With Nail.
那，对我和来说，那是其中的一部。我当时已经是你的超级粉丝了。所以当我看到你在做这件事的时候，我就加入了。我想看。然后看着它，我真的感到非常震惊，而且你也和伟大的保罗·麦甘一起演，我很崇拜他，因为我最喜欢的电影当然是《我与长指甲》（Withnail and I）。
And seeing Paul do that with you. Yeah. You know what was crazy about being working back in America in England was that I had to do an English accent. I had to just play an English character and, you know, Loose's London kind of like, you know, this kid that his dad was in the army so he traveled a bit, whatever.
看到保罗和你一起演。是的。你知道在英国重新开始工作有什么疯狂的吗？我得说英国口音。我必须扮演一个英国角色，你知道的，路德的伦敦背景，你知道的，这个小孩的爸爸在军队里，所以他到处旅行，诸如此类的。
But I couldn't really let go of my Americanisms. Wow. And everyone was like, and the people in the crew that thought that Stringer Bell was American was saying to me, your English accent is not bad. That's hysterical. That's funny. And I was home. I was like, yeah, it's not an accent, man. I'm English.
但我真的无法摆脱我的美国腔。哇。每个人都说，剧组里那些以为斯特林·贝尔（Stringer Bell）是美国人的家伙对我说，你的英国口音不赖嘛。太搞笑了吧。太好笑了。我当时在家。我就想，这根本不是口音，老兄。我是英国人。
Like, your English took that way. Anyway. Now, how do you like the big, big difference between the grind, the workload of being a lead in a drama, a one-hour drama, where you're in every scene, working 12-hour days versus the big, huge budget films that you've done where there's tons and tons of action, where you might only shoot maybe like a half a page for like two days. Yeah. You know, where you're kind of sitting around a lot, waiting for effects to set up
就像，你们英国人把那当回事。不管怎样。现在，你觉得在戏剧里当主角的这种高强度、工作量，一个小时的剧里你每场戏都在，每天工作12个小时，和那些你拍过的大制作电影相比，有什么巨大的区别？电影里有大量的动作戏，你可能拍两天也就拍个半页。是的。你知道的，你基本上就是在那里闲坐着，等着特效布置好
or stunts to set up. What's your preference or do you like to just kind of do half and half? I mean, I'm going to film in the moment, which is very big. Huge setups, you know, we shoot. What is it? What is it? It's a film called The Heads of State. Yeah.
或者特技布置好。你更喜欢哪种，还是说你喜欢各占一半？我的意思是，我正在拍的那部电影，规模非常大。庞大的场景布置，你知道的，我们拍摄。叫什么？叫什么？那是一部叫《国家卫队》（The Heads of State）的电影。是的。
Heads of State. I play the British Prime minister and John Cena plays. Okay, guys, the, you are. The American president. President. Yeah. Okay.
《国家卫队》。我扮演英国首相，约翰·塞纳扮演。好了，伙计们，你们是。美国总统。总统。是的。好吧。
Stay with me. And it's a big action comedy. And it's kind of like, you know, very big cumbersome setups. Slow, right? Yeah. And to your point, you know, very big cumbersome setups slow, right? And to your point, you know, Jay, I've come from, you know, TV backgrounds. We shoot very quickly. We move quickly. And we try to achieve the impossible very quickly.
听我说。这是一部大型动作喜剧。就像是，你知道的，非常庞大笨重的场景布置。很慢，对吧？是的。正如你所说，你知道的，杰伊，我是从，你知道的，电视背景出身的。我们拍摄速度很快。我们行动迅速。我们试图非常迅速地实现不可能的任务。
And I love the pacing of that. I really do. I enjoy it. You got to be good fast. Right. You can't be good on take four. You have to take one. You have to take one. You got to be good fast. You can't be good on take four. You're going to take one. You're a good fuss. And I think there's a real sort of satisfaction to that pacing. But of course, you know, the big films allow you to really dig in and do some incredible,
我喜欢这种节奏。真的。我很享受。你必须很快就能表现好。对的。你不能在第四条才演好。你必须在第一条。你必须在第一条。你必须快而好。你不能在第四条才演好。你得在第一条就行。你得又快又好。我觉得这种节奏有一种真正的满足感。但当然，你知道的，大电影能让你真正深入进去，做一些不可思议的，
you know, on budgets that are, you know. It's a weird, it is a weird thing. I remember that first time doing a big budget film and doing J.A. to your point, like coming in and doing like a, you know, maybe a eighth of a page or something on some big set up for the day. Right. And there's one line. You and me and the other person in the scene had one line each. We just had this.
你知道的，在那些，你知道的预算下。这很奇怪，确实是一件奇怪的事情。我记得第一次拍大预算电影的时候，杰伊，正如你所说，进去拍个，你知道的，可能八分之一页的东西，或者在某个大型场景里呆上一整天。对的。里面就一句台词。你、我和场景里的另一个人各有一句台词。我们只有这个。
I said something that she said something back to me. And they're like, yeah, this is really good. We feel really good. It's hard in the director and their producers are like, we got a great day and we're gonna get this thing. And we should just talk about this script, you know, talk about it. I go, the two lines, what are you talking about?
我说了一句，她回了我一句。然后他们就说，是的，这真的很好。我们感觉非常好。导演和制片人很难办，他们会说，我们今天过得很棒，我们要搞定这个。我们应该讨论一下这个剧本，你知道的，讨论一下。我说，就两台词，你们在说什么？
Like, okay, we don't need to have much of a conversation. You guys just want to run that a few times or workshop, like, are we talking about? And like, to your point, Idris, as you know, you're making HBO and both of you guys know as well. You're going like, you work on shows where sometimes you do nine, ten pages a day where you're running a day. Man, right, right. Right. Yeah. What about now, you're, you're, you're, uh, you're enjoying directing lately as well, too, right? And, and, and are you, are you, uh, are you enjoying, uh, bigger scale things, smaller scale things, what type of directing
就像，好吧，我们不需要聊太多。你们只是想把那几句过几遍或者排练一下，我们在说什么？而且，正如你所说的，伊德瑞斯，你也知道，你拍过HBO的剧，你们两个也都知道。你会去那种，有时候一天拍九页、十页的剧组，你得一路赶进度。老兄，对的，对的。对的。是的。那现在呢，你，你，你，呃，你最近也挺喜欢当导演的，对吧？而且，而且，而且，你，你，呃，你喜欢更大规模的东西，还是更小规模的东西，你对什么类型的导演工作
are you excited about, right? I directed a bunch of small scale things, like music videos and short content, small type things, okay? Little bit of TV. And that was the beginning. And I just enjoyed the process of just being you know, being given a music video. I did a music video for the month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and members. Isn't that why? And it was like a comedic sort of West China type of thing. Yeah, it was fun. Guys, you know, I, my wife and I have this big crush on Jason
感到兴奋呢？我导演过一堆小规模的东西，比如音乐录影带和短片内容，小体量的那种，好吧？一点点电视剧。那就是开始。我只是享受那种过程，就是，你知道的，给你一个音乐视频。我给……拍了一个音乐视频，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个，拍了一个非常喜剧化的西式风格。是的，挺有趣的。伙计们，你知道的，我和我妻子对杰森·贝特曼（Jason Bateman）迷恋得不行，你知道的，我们经常聊起这个。你知道的，我们甚至在派对上遇到过他，我们尝试着模仿杰森·贝特曼，然后压力就在杰森·贝特曼面前来了。当时真尴尬。但我妻子说，老兄，你对他迷恋得太夸张了，我当时就想，啊，没有啦，我只是挺喜欢这个家伙的。现在，现在，肖恩，你后背上。
Bateman, and you know, we've talked about this a lot. And you know, we even, we met him at a party, and we tried to do Jason Bateman, and then pressure was in front of Jason Bateman. It was embarrassing. But my wife was like, dude, you have a massive crush with her and I was like, ah, no, I just like the guy. And now, now, show up your back, Tat.
把你后背上的纹身展示出来。好吧，其实是我的屁股。现在，现在我们，在梅根·特娜（Meghan Thee Stallion）的MV里。哦，我知道，这简直是更上一层楼。我知道，确实如此。现在，你对杰森的模仿，听起来是不是很像90年代的调制解调器？是的。或者就是一个拨号音。
Show up the Tat to go on your back. Okay, so my bum actually. Now, and now we, we was in a month in a son's video. Oh, I know, this is just up to the ante. I know, it really has. Now, does your impression of Jason, does it sound a lot like a modem from the 90s? Yeah. Or just a dial tone.
退后。杰森，真可爱。你知道，伊德瑞斯有个……这可不可爱。我们见过几次面，他是个非常好非常好的人。这是个好人。我喜欢这样。我不知道，你知道的。
Rail back. Jason, that's cute. Did you know that that, uh, Idris had a... It's not cute. We have, we have met a few times and he's a very, very nice man. This is a nice man. I love that. I didn't know that, you know.
哇，品味真惊人。品味真惊人。你在硬夸。你在硬夸。我知道，我只是想，我也爱你，顺便说一句。我想让他，我想让他有反应。机器人是不会有反应的。是的。
Wow, incredible taste. What a credible taste. You're reaching. You're reaching. I know, I'm trying to, I love you too, by the way. I'm trying to get him to, I'm trying to get him to react. Robots don't react. Yeah.
你应该看看他的脸。两个书呆子的问题。我是《异星觉醒》/《异形》的超级粉丝，我爱你，对我来说这个。你之前就是《异形》系列的粉丝吗？和雷德利·斯科特合作并身处那些如此宏大且惊人的片场是什么感觉？是的，我是《异形》的超级粉丝。
You should have see his face. Two nerd questions. I'm a massive aliens fan, and I love you and for me this. And were you a fan of the alien franchise before? What was it like working with Ridley Scott and being on those sets, which were just so massive? And amazing. Yes, I was a massive fan of aliens.
我不会说自己是狂热粉丝，我不知道，你知道，全部，但我喜欢超级喜欢《异形》。我不会说自己是狂热粉丝，我不知道，你知道所有细节，但我喜欢这部电影。我真的很，好吧。我知道关于《异形》的一切。那我可要让你失望了。但我曾经是雷德利的超级粉丝，现在也是，我正努力回忆，我和雷德利合作过《美国黑帮》。他让我客串了《美国黑帮》里的一个小角色，然后我拿到了《普罗米修斯》，那是个稍微大一点的角色。所以这是我第二次和他合作。《普罗米修斯》简直是，你知道的，
I wouldn't say like, fanatic, I didn't know, you know, the whole, but I loved the massive fan of aliens. I wouldn't say like fanatic. I didn't know you know the whole but I loved the film I did just you really okay. I know everything about aliens. I'm gonna disappoint you then but I was a big fan of Ridley a have and and still am and I'm trying to remember but I'd worked with Ridley on American gangster and I'm He asked me to play a small party in American Gangsta, and then I got Prometheus, which is slightly bigger part. But so there's my second time working with him. Prometheus was, I mean, you know,
它的规模太疯狂了。雷德利非常注重实景拍摄。这正好在那种，你知道的，那种虚拟制作兴起之前，对吧，对吧，虚拟制作。是的。正如我看到的剧照，我看到了一张片场的照片。简直难以置信。是的。
it's just like the scale of it was bonkers. And really is very much an actuality guy. This is just before the sort of like, you know, the sort of virtual production, you know, right, right, productions. Yeah. As I saw the shot, I saw a picture photo of the set. It's just unbelievable. Yeah.
嗯，那些东西太神奇了。但你是说在那种他们做投影墙的事情之前，我们之前讨论过的，是的，跟菲罗（Pharaoh）合作的那样。跟菲罗。是的。那种制作风格已经接管了一切，这也没什么。但在过去，比如《普罗米修斯》和《异形》，他们搭建了这些布景，你知道的，而且很明显，而且《普罗米修斯》太棒了。
Well, that stuff is amazing. But you mean like before the thing where they do the projection wall that we talked about with, yes, with Pharaoh. With Pharaoh. Yeah. That style of production is taken over and that's fair enough. But back, like, Prometheus and aliens, they built these sets, you know, and obviously and, and Prometheus was amazing.
我记得最后那个家伙，你知道的，那个巨大的白色异形。剧透警告。是的，是的，是的，不，继续。我喜欢。你知道，我不需要继续了，因为你知道的。所以没有威亚，没有《普罗米修斯》。不需要继续了，因为你知道。肖恩，告诉我们这一幕里发生了什么。所以那个东西出来了，感觉就像，哇。
And I remember the, the guy at the end, you know, the big white alien. Spoiler alert. Yeah, yeah, yeah, no, keep going. I love it. You know, I don't need to keep going because you know. So no wire, no Prometheus. Don't need to keep going because you know. So no wire, no permitheus, don't need to see those. Sean, tell us what happens in the scene. So the thing comes out and it's like, wow.
是的。然后那家伙就说，是的，顺便说一句，你知道那个，那个工程师，告诉他们是怎么做出来的？他们当然知道了。顺便说一句，伊德瑞斯，你知道根据我的计算，我，是的。是的。是的，肖恩，我，你知道根据我的计算，我……是的。是的，我确实……
Yeah. And the guys like, yeah, by the way, do you know how that, the engineer tell them how they did it? They know by all means. By the way, you'd risked, did you know that, according to my calculations, I, yeah. Yeah. Yeah, I show, and I, did you know that, according to my calculations, I... Yeah. Yeah, I sure...
我确实知道那个工程师，那个真人……现实生活中的那个工程师身高大约八英尺。哇。在现实生活中。你知道他是以谁为原型的吗？他们设计它是基于……部分设计是基于斯塔夫，自由……哦，是的。
I do know that that engineer, the actual man... That engineer in real life is about eight-foot tall. Wow. In real life. And you know what he's based on? They designed it based on... Partly designed based on staff, the staff, the liberty of the... Oh, yes.
脸部的对称性。我知道这个。你怎么能联系上斯科特的，你到底是怎么做到的？部分设计是基于斯塔夫，自由。哦，是的。脸部的对称性。我知道这个。你怎么能联系上斯科特的，你到底是怎么做到的？是的，你是什……现在，你知道的，伊德瑞斯和我一起演过一部电影。你们知道吗？
The symmetry of the face. I know this. How did you ever land, Scotty? How did you ever get there? have partly designed based on staff, the staff, the liberty. Oh, yes. The symmetry of the face. I know this. How did you ever land, Scotty? How did you ever get that? Yeah, what are you? Now, you know, Idris and I have been in a film together. Did you guys know that?
不，是什么？是什么？它叫《疯狂动物园》，他在里面用令人难以置信的金嗓子为伊德瑞斯这个角色配音。他演的是牛局长（Chief Bogo）。牛局长。他是美洲豹还是老虎？都不是。
No, what is it? What is it? It's called Zitopia, where he uses incredible golden pipes to voice the character of Idris. And he had Captain Bogo actually. Captain Bogo. Was he a panther or tiger? Neither.
哦，不，是水牛。水牛。对，对，对，对。能请你告诉我，有传言说你要出演新的《星球大战》电影吗？能请你告诉我这是真的吗？你不能谈论这个。
Yeah. Oh, no, the water buffalo. Water buffalo. Yep, yep, yep, yep. Can you please tell me it's been rumored that you're gonna be in the new Star Wars movie? Can you please tell me if that's true? You can't speak about that.
不，我没参演，不，不，我真的。有这个传言。因为有传言说你要出演新的《星球大战》电影。能请你告诉我这是真的吗？他不能谈论这个。不，我没参演。不，不，我真的。有这个传言。因为有传言说你要去星战……这是新闻报道吗，肖恩？不，并不是。谁开始的传言，斯科蒂？我刚才自己开始的。
No, I'm not in it, no, no, I'm really. There's a rumor. Because there's rumors that you're going to be in the new Star Wars movie. Can you please tell me if that's true? He can't speak about that. No, I'm not in it. No, no, I'm really. There's a rumor. Because there's rumors that you're going to be in the new Star Wars journalism, Sean. No, not so. Who started the rumor, Scotty? I just started it now.
谁挑起的话头？根据我开始的那条留言板消息。我读到了。我确实读到了。我在几个地方读到了。但你可能对此吞吞吐吐，不过谁知道呢？我不读那个。我确实在几个地方读到过，但你可能对此吞吞吐吐，谁知道呢，我不知道。现在，如果你明天能拿到任何一场音乐会的门票，
Who started you one? According to the message boards that I started that. I read it. I did read that. I did read that a couple of places. But you may be coy about it, but who knows? I don't read that. I did read that a couple of places, but you may be coy about it, who knows, I don't know. Now what about, if you could have tickets to any concert tomorrow,
会是什么票，会是谁的演唱会？现在谁在燃爆你的世界？现在的任何音乐会。碧昂丝、泰勒·斯威夫特。现在的音乐会。嗯，碧昂丝、泰勒·斯威夫特。是的，必须是个斯威夫蒂（Swiftie）。好吧，可以是我想要的任何人吗？是的，是的。是的。
what would they be, who would they be for? Who's rocking your world right now? Any concert right now. Be science Taylor Swift. concert right now. Um, be science-tailor swift. Yeah, just have to be a swift. Okay, can it be anyone that I would like? Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
好吧，首先，现在在英国，有一个这样的ABBA乐队的全息投影演出。是的，是的，是的。我听说这个很棒。是的，我想去看。显然它不可思议。是的。
Yeah. Okay, so first of all, in England right now, there's this sort of production of Abba. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. I've heard about this that it's great. Yeah, and I want to say it. Apparently it's incredible. Yeah.
我还没机会去看，我想去。因为这真是一个奇迹。有全息图，你知道的，简直不可思议。那会是一个真正的，我喜欢音乐，所以那会很棒。你是ABBA的粉丝吗？你是ABBA的粉丝吗？是的。好吧。
And I haven't had a chance to do it, and I want to do it. Because it's a marvel. There's holograms and, you know, just incredible. And that would be a real, I love music, so that would be great. Are you an Abba fan? Are you an Abba fan? Yeah. Okay.
这就是你能给出的那种欢呼。这算是什么赞美。算什么赞美。不，等等，等等，听着，我是，但我的意思是，我不知道，我不知道，我只是，你知道的，每个人都或多或少有点喜欢ABBA。是的，肯定的。你知道，你知道的，所以，是的，ABBA总是很受欢迎。
That's about the kind of yell. You can give us. That's what an endorsement. What an endorsement. No, hold on hold on listen, I am, but I mean, I don't know, I don't know, I just, you know, everyone loves it a little bit of a abba. Yeah, for sure. I did you know as you know, so, yeah, abba always works.
好吧，难道不是吗，他们不是在环球影业拍了那部关于ABBA的电影吗？《妈妈咪呀》（Mamma Mia）。《妈妈咪呀》，那是关于ABBA的对吧？是的，根据音乐剧改编的。哦，它是根据ABBA的歌改编的，然后他们拍了，是的，然后是的。粉丝们好像拍了两部。什么？他们拍了吗？我记得他们拍了第二部，我只是好奇。他们叫什么来着？好像叫《爸爸咪呀》。我们又来一次。爸爸咪呀？我们又来一次。我们又来一次。爸爸。我们来了。我们又来一次。这挺不错的。但它说的是，但更像是“我们又来一次”。这挺好。这挺好。其实我挺喜欢的。我喜欢它。皮尔斯·布鲁斯南（Pierce Brosnan）向你问好。我喜欢这个，老兄。说到皮尔斯·布鲁斯南，前任007。
Well, isn't it, didn't they do that, the, the movie at Universal about abba? Mama Mia. Mama Mia, that's about abba right? Yeah based on the musical. Oh it's based on a song that Abba song and then they made them yeah and then yeah. The fans made two of those I think. What? Did they they did? I think they called it a second one I'm just curious. What do they call it? It was called Daddy Mia. Here we go again. Daddy Mia? Here we go again. Here we go again. Daddy. We are here. We go again. That's pretty good. But it was said, but it said more like there we go again. That's kind. That's kind. I actually like it. I like it. Pierce Brosnan sends his love. I love that, dude. Speaking of Pierce Brosnan, former double seven.
不，别这样。拜托，求你了。什么？那是开玩笑吗？不，我想知道的是，不是，当，考虑到那些关于伊德瑞斯将要扮演詹姆斯·邦德的无休止的传言。我想问的是，谁在演詹姆斯·邦德？有很多传言说伊德瑞斯将成为詹姆斯·邦德。
No, don't do it. Come on, please. What? Was that a noite? No, what I want to know is, I'm not, when, consider all those rumors that forever that Idris was going to play James Bond. What I want to ask, who is playing James Bond? There were lots of rumors that Idris was going to be James Bond.
是的，我记得持续了好多年好多年。是的，我听说了。好选择。太棒了。所以我的问题是，你，那个过程是不是烦死人了，得应付每隔两秒就来问你的所有人？不，烦人的是，你知道的，在宣传
Yes, I remember for years and years and years. Yeah, I heard that. Good choice. So amazing. And so my question is this, did you, was that process so fucking annoying dealing with everybody asking you every two seconds? No, annoying would be, you know, being asked about it over and over again on different podcasts while promoting
我们从未谈论过的《劫机七小时》时，在不同的播客上一次又一次地被问到这件事。我们没在谈论这个。不，我想问你关于被追问这个的过程。是的，是的。事实是，老兄，很长一段时间里我对此都感到超级荣幸。我当时想，你知道的，哇，这太疯狂了，你知道的，因为詹姆斯·邦德，我们都是演员，我们理解那个角色是那种，你知道的，梦寐以求的类型，你知道的，就像被评为最性感男人一样。哦，是的，我真的无法解释。
hijack that we've never spoken about. We're not speaking about it. No, I want to ask you about the process of being asked about it. Yeah, yeah. The truth is, man, I was super complimented for a long time about this. I was like, you know, well, this is crazy, You know, because James Bond, we're all actors and we understand that, that role is one of those sort of, you know, coveted type, you know, it's like being named sexist man. Oh, yeah, I can't really explain.
哦，抱歉。哦，是的，我没法解释这个。他真是厌烦透了。真是不好意思。但是，但是，你知道的，被邀请去扮演詹姆斯·邦德就像是，好吧，你知道的，你算是达到了一个巅峰，你知道的，这差不多是那种
Oh, sorry. Oh, yeah, I can't explain that. He's so sick of that. Sorry about that. But, but being, you know, asked to be James Bond was like, okay, you know, you sort of reached a pinnacle, you know, that's kind of one of these things
全世界都会投票支持的事情。而且，本质上，这是一种巨大的赞美，世界的每一个角落——除了某些我们不会谈论的角落——都对我有机会被考虑这个想法感到非常高兴。
that the whole world sort of has a vote in. And, you know, essentially, it was a huge sort of compliment that every corner of the world except for some corners, which we will not talk about, we're really happy about the idea that I could be considered.
那些对我有机会被考虑这个想法感到不高兴的人。那些不高兴的人把整件事讨论得偏离了重点，你知道的，因为这变成了关于种族的问题，变成了无稽之谈，老兄。而我承受了最沉重的打击。是的，这他妈全都是扯淡。到底是谁演的？现在到底谁在演詹姆斯·邦德？是谁？现在没有人。
The those that weren't happy about the idea that I could be considered. The those that weren't happy about the idea made the whole thing discussed in an off-point, you know, because it became about race and it became about nonsense, dude. And I got the brunt of it. Yeah, it's fucking bullshit. Who did get it? Who's playing James Bond right now? Who is it? Nobody now.
他们还没决定吗？是的，他们还没定。我想他们都，懂了。好吧。你在给谁发信息，杰森？你在给你的经纪人发短信吗？是的，这太疯狂了。如果你哪怕想哪怕一秒钟，
They haven't decided? Yeah, they haven't. I think they're all gotcha. All right. Who are you texting Jason? Are you texting your agent? Yeah, that's crazy. If you think for a fucking,
但你知道，但伊德瑞斯没空去演詹姆斯·邦德，因为他要忙着拍《劫机七小时2》呢。《劫机七小时》，因为《劫机七小时》。不，但是《劫机七小时》真的太棒了。他演得很好。最近刚在Apple上线的。最流畅的趋势是，我是说，对的。
but you know, but interest is not available to play James Bond, because he's going to be busy doing hijack too. hijack, because hijack. No, but hijack is going to be so good. He is good. Recently out on Apple. The smoothest trend is I mean right.
他现在还是里面的执行制片人。作为执行制片人。你，你在做关于现在已经播出的《劫机七小时》的事吗？是的，是的，在Apple上。是的，你还没看呢。得了吧。是的，我会看的。他在里面演一个乘务员，对吧？一个男空中乘务员。不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，屏幕上，但其实是在阅读。我得弄一个那个。你可以一边研究一边谈论人们看着你。才没有那回事呢。这太不可思议了。
He's also an executive producer on it now as an executive producer. Are you are you doing about hijack that's out right now? Yeah, yeah, an apple. Yeah, you're not seeing it. Yeah, come on. Yes, I'm going to see it. He plays a steward, right? A male flight attendant on it. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, screen, but actually it's reading. I need to get one of those. You can research and speak at the same time about people watching you. No, any of that stuff. This is incredible.
这真的是一个，这真的是一个聪明的聊天和搞笑节目。所以你在《劫机七小时》里演什么？你是，你是，你是好人还是坏人在《劫机七小时》里？你在《劫机七小时》里是使坏的吗？所以，我演。我演。我演一个男妓，然后……哇。所以你要帮我？很忙。给你。不，我演……一个叫萨姆·纳尔逊（Sam Nelson）的家伙，他在迪拜工作，或者正在迪拜工作，他是个商业谈判专家。他基本上，你知道的，负责处理并购案的最后细节。
This is a real, this is a real, this is a smart list chat and giggle. So what do you play in hijack? Are you, are you, are you helping or you hurting on hijack? you hurting on hygiene? So I play. I play. I play a male prostitute who... Wow. So you're going to help me? Busy. There you go. No, I play... A guy called Sam Nelson who works in Dubai, or is working in Dubai, He's a business closer. He kind of, you know, does the last minute finalities
关于并购。是的。他结了婚，但他和妻子正经历一些疯狂的事情，他决定坐飞机回家去解决问题。好吧。他抛弃了他的生意。剧里看不到这些，但你后来会知道。
on to merge an merger. Yeah. He's married, but he and his wife are going for some crazy, and he decides to get on a plane to go home to sort it out. Okay. He abandoned his business. You don't see any of that, but you learn it later.
而在飞机上，基本上，发生了一场劫机。他因为家里正经历危机而急着想回家。他决定利用他的商业谈判、促成交易的技巧来弄清楚这群劫机者到底是什么人，这倒是个好主意。他决定纯粹靠脑力来做到这一点，
And on the plane, basically, there's a hijack. And he's so desperate to get home because he's a marriageist for him in the part of the day. He decides that it's a good idea to use his business negotiation, closing skills to basically figure out who this cell of hijackers are. And he decides to do it literally by brain power,
试图用个性和交谈以及问问题来消磨他们的意志，从而切入他们的内心。事情就是这样发展的，挺好的。这发生在你的拳头里。好吧，这就是我们所做的。是的，如果你在晚上只和人说话，通过跟人沟通而不是打拳，你也能把事情办成。这部剧很棒，因为它是实时发生的，总共六集、七集，每个小时发生一集。真的是这样吗，哦，太酷了。哦，天哪。这真的很酷。是的。
by trying to wear them down with personality and talking and asking questions and just getting under the skin And that's what happens nice. It happens in your fists. Well, that's what we do Yeah, well if you just talk to people in your nights, people instead of punching people you can get things And the show's great because it's it's like a real time so six episode seven episodes and it happens each hour Is in really oh that's cool. Oh, man. It's really cool. Yeah. So it's six episodes and it happens each hour. It's in real time. Oh, that's cool. Oh, man. It's really cool. Yeah.
是的，我喜欢这个。等等，现在，我还记得听到过一些关于你开了一家营销公司的消息。是真的吗？是的。我有说错任何事吗？没错。为什么？
Yeah. I love that. Wait, now, I also remember hearing something about you starting a marketing agency. Is that true? Yeah. I'm getting any of that, right? That's right. Why?
我们刚刚宣布了这个消息，其实。为什么？哦，你宣布了？我最近在哪里读到过。是的。为什么？这有什么让人兴奋的。好吧，马克·博恩（Mark Boyen），他非常成功，拥有一家非常成功的营销公司叫
We just announced that, actually. Why? Oh, you did? I read it somewhere recently. Yeah. Why? And what's exciting about it. Okay, so Mark Boyen, who is a very successful, and owns this very successful marketing company called
Meroma。Meroma和我合作创建了一家名为Sillyface的公司。Sillyface是一家营销代理机构，我想它的设计初衷是为了寻找方法，将乐趣重新注入营销中去。听着，你知道的，正如你在我的介绍里读到的那样。你知道的，我是个多面手。
Meroma. And Meroma and I have worked together to create a company called Sillyface. Sillyface is a market-set agency, which is, I guess designed to sort of find ways to inject, put, reignite, fun back into marketing. Look, you know, I'm a guy as you read my introduction. You know, I'm intersectional.
Meroma。Meroma和我一起创立了一家名为Sillyface的公司。Sillyface是一家市场营销代理公司，我想它的宗旨就是寻找各种方法，将乐趣重新注入、融入并点燃到市场营销中。你看，正如你从我的简介中所读到的那样，我是一个注重交叉性的人。
You can say that about me. And I think that in this day and day of a really smart consumers and brands wanting to be intersectional and trying to do different things, you know, there's a misconnect, you know. Consumers are like, really dark, your Mars chocolate, why are you trying to sell me music? Right. And you know, that whole intersectionality needs navigating, needs, you know, and I honestly, I find myself in a situation where I can actually speak on this quite intelligently
你可以这样评价我。而且我认为在如今这个时代，消费者非常聪明，品牌也希望跨界并尝试不同的事物，你知道的，这中间其实存在一个脱节。消费者会想：‘等等，你是玛氏巧克力，为什么要向我推销音乐？’对吧？你知道的，这种跨界需要去摸索、需要去经营，说实话，我发现自己正处于一个能够非常理智地谈论这个话题的位置。
that I think it's okay for people to try different things. I think it's okay for, you know, I don't know, brands to want to reach out in different areas and try different ways to reach new audiences. But I think it needs to be done of integrity and smart. I think storytelling is at the heart of it. You know what I mean? I didn't come here with a marketing degree.
我觉得人们尝试不同的事情是没有问题的。我认为，我不知道，品牌想要涉足不同的领域并尝试各种方式去触达新的受众也是可以的。但我觉得这需要以真诚和智慧来完成。我认为讲故事才是核心。你知道我的意思吗？我来这儿可不是带着市场营销学位的。
I'm a storyteller. And I tell many different stories. So as you read me, oh, so you kickboxed, okay, yeah, I can talk about it intelligently. It doesn't make it inauthentic that I did it, but you, you know, the story is that I did it. Here's my reasons why. So if a brand is at this junction where they're like,
我是一个讲故事的人。而且我讲过很多不同的故事。所以当你了解我时，‘哦，原来你练过自由搏击，’好的，是的，我可以头头是道地谈论它。这并不意味着我做过这件事就是虚假的，事实是我的确经历过。原因就在这里。所以如果某个品牌正处于这样一个十字路口，他们会想：
I want to market into a new area, I'm not sure who to go to, you can go to many marketing companies, the world doesn't need a new one. However, Mark and I have this sort of philosophy around trying to do it in a way that makes sense for the consumer as well as it does for the brand. You know what I'm saying?
‘我想开拓一个新的营销领域，但不确定该找谁，’你可以去找许多营销公司，这个世界并不缺一家新公司。不过，我和马克有一种这样的理念：努力以一种对消费者和品牌都合理的方式去做这件事。你知道我在说什么吗？
Cool. Were you always super motivated when you were a kid? Like, were your parents? Did they tell you early on, like, you got to go out there and get what you want? And because it seems like you just have no quit in you. I love that.
太酷了。你小时候一直都超级有动力吗？比如说，你的父母呢？他们很早就告诉你，比如，你必须走出去，去争取你想要的东西吗？因为看起来你骨子里就有一股不服输的劲头。我很喜欢这一点。
Great work ethic, yeah? I think the answer is yes, if I'm really honest, part of the overshare, but my mom, you know, she tried for children for a while, and it was hard, it was really hard. I came along and she was like, and I think she just, I guess she carried this little bit of sort of, you know, sense for the children that she didn't manage to bear and just wanted me to be the best I could be in wind. Go and go and go. And it wasn't like she was out there. She's not the cause. She's always telling me, you should have been like, why are you doing so much?
极佳的职业道德，是吗？我想答案是肯定的，如果我足够坦诚的话——这也算是一点过度分享吧——但我妈妈，你知道的，她曾尝试要孩子好一段时间，过程很艰难，真的很难。后来我降生了，她就觉得……我想她大概带着这样一种情结：为了那些她没能生下来的孩子们，她希望我能做到最好，去赢。拼命向前冲，冲，冲。倒不是说她在外面逼我。她才不是那种人。她总是对我说：‘你何必这么拼？为什么要做这么多？’
But she also just said, you know, my man, like, you know, we're here and then we're not here. So do what you want and go for it, you know what I'm saying? And absolutely. 100%. I don't know how that transferred into a work ethic. I haven't always, I'm an only child, so number one, I was always sort of like using my imagination way more than any of my friends I knew. I just had the imagination. I just kept going like, oh, what if we did this? And whenever I would play out as a kid,
但她同时也会说：‘我的孩子，你知道的，我们在世上的时间有限，有生就有死。所以做你想做的事，放手去闯吧，’你知道我的意思吗？完全是这样。100%是这样。我不知道这怎么就转化成了一种职业道德。我一直以来……我是个独生子，所以首先，我总是比我认识的任何朋友都更能发挥想象力。我就是有着丰富的想象力。我总是不断地想：‘哦，如果我们这样做会怎么样？’而且每当我小时候出去玩的时候，
go out to play with my friends wherever it's outside. I'd always be the one that's like, do we have to go home now? We have to go home, let's go, let's go, let's go. Because I didn't have siblings. And so I think that transferred to basically a place where as an artist, and here's a thing, guys, you know this, right?
和朋友们在外面玩耍时，无论在哪儿。我总是那个会说：‘我们现在非得回家吗？非得回家吗？走吧，走吧，走吧。’因为我没有兄弟姐妹。所以我想这最终转化成了一种状态：作为一名艺术家，而且有一点，伙计们，你们也知道，对吧？
We as actors so like, spoilt, we are privileged, we get offered so much that it takes many people years to get business opportunities, you know, Conversations and I look at I'm sitting down with the likes of you guys No, but I mean it's it's not a every day. You gotta tell you bottom before you can push up We promise this will be your bottom But trust me when I say from my perspective to come in here and speak to you guys who, you know, I respect so much, that's a privilege.
我们作为演员真是被宠坏了，我们享有特权，我们得到的商业机会是很多人需要花好几年才能得到的，你知道的，还有各种对话。我看着自己能和你们这样的人坐在一起。不，我的意思是，这可不是天天都有的。你得先跌落谷底，才能重新振作。我们向你保证，这绝对是你的谷底。但相信我，从我的角度来看，能来到这里和你们这些我如此尊重的人对话，这是一种特权。
And to take advantage of that is something that I think is just kind of like why I find myself taking advantage of an opportunity all the time. So I DJ, I love DJ, I love DJ, so someone says to me, you want to do that role wedding? Yeah, of course. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Why not? I tell the story. Trust me, but I'm not one of these people that just needs to be famous, or wants to be famous, or just needs to do things just for like,
而利用好这一点，我想这就是为什么我发现自己一直在抓住任何机会。所以我去打碟，我热爱打碟，我太爱打碟了，所以当有人对我说：‘你想去那场婚礼上做这个吗？’‘好啊，当然。行，行，行，行。为什么不呢？’我去讲这个故事。相信我，但我并不是那种迫切需要出名、渴望出名、或者仅仅为了……而去做事的人。
the most of the things that I really, really do, I don't really ever hit the news headlines and I prefer that. However, it is what it is. Yeah, I've noticed that about you. You're a massive star and you do not lean into it. You don't see a lot of pictures of you out, you know, movie premieres and cutting ribbons and, you know, lighten your hair on fire and say,
我真正做的绝大多数事情，其实从来都没上过新闻头条，我也更喜欢这样。不过，事情就是这样。是的，我注意到你这一点了。你是个超级巨星，但你一点也不刻意彰显。你很少看到有照片拍到你出席电影首映礼、剪彩，或者把自己的头发点燃然后大喊：
and look at me, I'm famous. You just, you just work constantly at the highest level with great people on great projects and you're just doing your work and the fame just comes with that, yeah? I take that observation and I appreciate that. I think I'd say that, you know, long-jevety, yeah, that's the goal. That's the goal, you know, and-jeivity, you know. That's the goal.
‘看我，我很出名。’你只是，你只是在最高水平上与优秀的人合作优秀的项目，不断地工作，而名气自然而然就随之而来了，是吗？我接受这个评价，也很感激。我想说的是，长青，是的，这才是目标。这才是目标，你知道的，长青，你知道的。这才是目标。
That's the goal, you know. And I think people can get exhausted, especially if someone like me, it's like, oh, you're in a rap video now, what the fuck, you know what I'm saying? Like, yeah, people can get exhausted. I think I've exhausted the three of you today, already.
这才是目标，你知道的。而且我认为人们会感到精疲力竭，尤其是像我这样的人，大家会觉得：‘哦，你现在居然跑去拍说唱MV了，搞什么鬼，’你知道我在说什么吗？就像是，是的，人们确实会感到疲惫。我觉得今天我已经把你们三位给累垮了。
Oh my God. Are you kidding me? No, I'm serious, I know I have, but the truth is, like, if you, truth is, I think people tend to find, especially now these days, we're all addicted to social media and wanting to feed the engine. We were talking about press junk, it's earlier.
天哪。你在开玩笑吗？不，我是认真的，我知道我确实把你们累着了，但事实是，如果你……事实是，我觉得人们往往会发现，尤其是现在这个时代，我们都沉迷于社交媒体，想要不断喂养这个机器。我们刚才还在聊宣传通告呢。
I mean, those things are resentful these days. They want to know everything, everything about you. So I just prefer to say this, and then when I have to say, I speak, you know, how old are your kids? Are they looking to get into this business at all? Yeah, I have a nine year old, uh, uh, 21 year old and a 30 year old and my 30 year old, he's an actor and, uh, he wants, he wants to grow in that space. Um, my 21 year old is in, in my use, in my you study.
我的意思是，现在这些采访真让人反感。他们什么都想知道，关于你的一切。所以我宁愿这样说：该说的时候我就说。你知道的，你的孩子多大？他们想进这行吗？是的，我有一个9岁的，一个21岁的和一个30岁的。我30岁的儿子是个演员，而且，他想在这个领域发展。我的21岁的孩子在……在读大学。
Nice. Yeah. Wow. This is great. And my nine year old wants in NYU studying. Nice. Yeah. Wow. She's great. And my 9 year old wants to be a gamer. That's great. Yeah. Okay.
太棒了。是的。哇。这太棒了。我9岁的女儿想在大学里学……太棒了。是的。哇。她很棒。我9岁的女儿想当个游戏玩家。太棒了。好吧。
Uh-huh. That was a profession not available to be a 30 year old and the 21 year old, right? Yeah. Laura. Yeah, although it's probably, don't they make more money on video games than they do in the in in movie in the movie industry? Yeah. Right? Doesn't like call it. It's been a while.
嗯哼。这可是30岁和21岁的人当年没有的职业选择，对吧？对。劳拉。对，不过大概，难道他们在电子游戏里赚的钱不比在电影行业里赚的得多吗？对吧？难道不是吗？……已经好一阵子了。
It's been a while now. Yeah, yeah, yeah. They've far subbed. All those big games, game titles, we'll, yeah, far outpace. One of those successful games, I think it was called a duty a few years ago, made more money than all the studios made. Combined.
已经好一阵子了。对，对，对。它们早就超越了。所有那些大型游戏，都会，是的，远远甩在后面。我记得几年前有一款很成功的游戏叫《使命召唤》，它的收入比所有电影制片厂的收入加起来还要多。
Cool. Did you? Good Lord. It just, we're 11 minutes over. We have 10 minutes to go. We're very sorry. Oh, you 11 minutes in your life. I'm happy to serve it back to you if you come back out to LA anytime soon.
太酷了。真的吗？我的天啊。我们已经超时11分钟了。还剩10分钟。非常抱歉。哦，你生命的11分钟。如果你最近什么时候再去洛杉矶，我很乐意还给你。
100% I'd love to. Do you guys do a live version of this on camera? That's all we have. We have done. We did that two years ago. And we may do it again. We're thinking about maybe doing it in Europe one of these days. But if we do, we're booking you in London. If that's not there, we filmed it. It's a doc that's out on Macs right now.
100%，我很愿意。你们会把这个做成带摄像机的直播版本吗？这就是我们所有的了。我们做过。我们两年前做过。而且我们以后可能还会做。我们在考虑也许哪天在欧洲搞一场。不过如果我们办的话，我们要把你在伦敦的行程订下来。如果没去现场的话，我们把它拍下来了。现在这部纪录片已经在Max上播出了。
Sick. I'm going to watch it. And you know, if you want any merchandise, let's give them the merchandise address, Sean. Yeah, guys, let's send them some merch. No, no, no, no, you know what? Let's send them a hat. Let's send them one. Let's for sure send Idris hat. Idris, thank you for being with us, my friend. Can't wait to see you again. The great No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, I appreciate you guys. It was very a lot of fun. Thank you, pal. Good to see you. Thanks, pal. Cheers, guys. All right.
太棒了。我要去看看。你知道的，如果你想要任何周边的话，肖恩，我们把周边的地址给他们吧。好的，伙计们，给他们寄点周边吧。不，不，不，你知道吗？给我们寄顶帽子吧。给我们寄一顶。一定要给伊德瑞斯寄顶帽子。伊德瑞斯，谢谢你能和我们在一起，我的朋友。迫不及待想再见到你。伟大的……不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不陷入混乱之中。感谢你们大家。非常有趣。谢谢你，老兄。很高兴见到你。谢谢，老兄。再见，伙计们。好了。
See you later. Now, Andrew Selba. That's a man. That's a man. That's a man. That's a cool giant tall man. He's a very big man. I met him once, briefly, I didn't want to bring it up,
回头见。刚才那是安德鲁·塞尔巴。那是个纯爷们。纯爷们。那是个酷炫的高个子巨人。他个子非常大。我曾经短暂地见过他一次，我当时没敢提这事，
because there's a really good chance he didn't remember. So I just didn't want to embarrass myself. Yeah. Well, that was pretty cool though. You weren't the guy that he beat up in his kickboxing match, were you? Um, I'm not surprised that he's undefeated there. No, I mean, either. He's a big dude and I was saying like he was saying, he was in that video where he's
因为他大概率已经不记得了。所以我就不想让自己尴尬。好吧，不过那其实挺酷的。你可不是他在自由搏击比赛里痛揍的那个家伙，对吧？呃，他至今保持不败，我一点也不觉得奇怪。不，我是说，我也是。他是个大块头，就像我刚才说的，他演过那个MV，他在里面
the guy who gets his bike still on the fuck with steel. He fuckwood steel interest hell but it's by a good like a dumb criminal I think it was called I think the song was called dumb criminal. Yeah, yeah, but he's he's a he's a he's a hero of mine that guy. Oh good. And Willie sounds like you've been following him for quite some time. Who me? Yeah. Oh, you're a big fan. Yeah. I'm a massive fan of his. I think he's got to jump back into the wire. Damn it. I know. He's been in like, you know, Thor and I feel like every girl I know has a crush on him. Yeah. Yeah. Well, suicide squad and fast and furious. And I mean, he wasn't I wouldn't talk about his part in the office. He did, he did some office work. It says Oh, yeah. He's also like the fact that he did a marketing company,
演那个单车被偷……去他的单车。他演的是《蠢贼》（Dumb Criminal），我觉得那首歌好像叫《蠢贼》。对，对，但他是……他真的是我的偶像，那个家伙。哦，好极了。听起来你关注他挺长时间了。我吗？对。哦，你是个超级粉丝。对。我是他的超级粉丝。我觉得他应该回归《火线》（The Wire）。该死。我懂的。他演过，你知道的，《雷神》，而且我觉得我认识的每个女生都对充满倾慕之情。对。对。还有《自杀小队》和《速度与激情》。我的意思是，我还没聊他在《办公室》里的角色呢。他演过，他客串过《办公室》。里面说……哦，对了。他甚至还搞了一家营销公司，
like he's all over, it's incredible. I know. It's very impressive. It is impressive. He's just like doing like a million things. That's what I say when I was like, we're not doing enough. No, you're not. You're really not.
他无处不在，这太不可思议了。我懂。这真的令人印象深刻。太令人印象深刻了。他简直同时在干上百万件事。这就是为什么我之前说我们做得还不够。不，你们确实不够。你们真的远远不够。
My favorite line of this whole episode was Jason calling cheese its Colin Sament. No. No. In a fun color. In behind my back. They're not. I'm in some shit.
我整期节目最喜欢的一句台词，就是杰森把芝脆香饼（Cheez-Its）叫成萨门（Salmon）。不。才不是。在一个有趣的颜色里。在我背后。它们才不是。我摊上事了。
Cheezits are great. They are great to our friends at Cheezits. Yeah, you get a bowl of cheezits when you watch a movie like that. That's my popcorn. Is it really? Yeah, I love it. It's not popcorn. It's not. No, it's not a. That also will back you up quite a bit. Popcorn. Popcorn. Well, you know what? I just read popcorn's not great for you. Why? No, it'll go the plug. Just really?
芝脆香饼太棒了。它们对我们的朋友芝脆香饼公司太好了。是的，你看这种电影时就会吃上一碗芝脆香饼。那就是我的爆米花。真的吗？对，我超爱。它可不是爆米花。才不是。不，它才不是。而且那东西也会让你堵得慌。爆米花。爆米花。好吧，你知道吗？我刚看到说爆米花对身体其实不太好。为什么？不，它会堵塞血管。真的吗？
I was just thinking about it. Yeah. Okay, Idris Elba is in a movie called hijack. I think he's trying to get to his buy. I am. Right, is hijack and his character he told us was working in. Do. Bye.
我刚刚才想到这个。好吧。好的，伊德瑞斯·艾尔巴主演了一部电影叫《劫机》（Hijack）。我想他是想去找他的买家。我是。对，是《劫机》，他的角色我们之前被告知是在……工作。再见。
Actually wrote it down so I wouldn't forget. Oh, smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjarv, and Bennett Barberco. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen Plus. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我其实把它写下来了，免得自己忘掉。哦，太聪明了。太聪明了。太聪明了。太聪明了。太聪明了。《聪明糊涂心》（SmartLess）是由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿姆贾夫和本尼特·巴伯科100%有机手工打造的。我们的下一期节目将在一个星期后发布，你可以在任何收听播客的地方听到，或者你也可以在Wondery+上收听。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。